Herzlich Willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge 16. Und wir wollen heute mal über Geld reden. Und ja, ansonsten hab ich nicht bemerkt.
Also das wird kein Spendenaufruf nicht falsch verstehen. Es geht um Währungen und was Geld eigentlich ist.
Ja, und wie der Wert hinter Geld eigentlich entsteht oder ob auch nicht entsteht und über diese Sachen wollen wir heute ein bisschen länger reden. Ihr habt vielleicht gemerkt, dass wir ein bisschen seltener gesendet haben, als wir uns vorgenommen haben, da sind uns ein paar Sachen dazwischen gekommen. Wir versuchen uns mal zu bessern, ohne grundsätzliche Versprechungen, aber wir versuchen es mal. Und ansonsten trotzdem nochmal herzlichen Dank, wo wir gerade bei Geld sind, fürs reichliche Flattern. Könnte gerne weiter tun, da freuen uns natürlich drüber. Und bisher haben wir ein paar Bücher davon gekauft, die wir auch in einer der nächsten Sendungen verwerten werden. Und lassen uns ansonsten auch noch interessante Dinge damit einfallen, mit dem Geld. Ja, das Geld. Geld ist ja so ein Thema, da kann man sich immer schön drüber streiten, aber man sagt ja auch irgendwie, beim Geld hört die Freundschaft auf. Das ist halt ein sehr emotionales Thema. Und interessanterweise ist es auch ein sehr emotionales Thema, wenn man sich mal darüber unterhält, was Geld denn nun eigentlich ist und was es bedeutet und wie es entsteht und warum es entsteht und welche Funktion es in unserem Leben hat. Und wir werden uns in dem Laufe dieser Sendung garantiert mit einigen Vertretern der volkswirtschaftlichen oder betriebswirtschaftlichen Autodoksi anlegen, deren Theorien ja doch mittlerweile doch den Charakter einer Lehrmeinung häufig haben und weniger eines wissenschaftlichen Beitrages, obwohl man natürlich sagen muss, dass gerade die Volkswirtschaftler doch sehr viel mehr davon verstehen, als was da passiert, als die Betriebswirtschaft hat.
Und es ist auch viel spannender, mit Volkswirten zu reden als mit Betriebswirten.
Ja.
Aber wir haben so ein bisschen einen Eindruck gewonnen bei unseren Recherchen, dass es, also die klassischen Anforderungen an eine Naturwissenschaft sind nur partiell gegeben. Also es gibt da Uneinigkeit schon bei Basisdefinitionen und bei Fragen, wie soll denn jetzt, also welche Ziele hat denn eine Geldpolitik überhaupt, soll der Staat überhaupt eine Geldpolitik haben oder sich ganz raushalten. Also schon bei so fundamentalen Fragen gibt es Uneinigkeit. Und die verschiedenen Theorien und es gibt Denkschulen, das ist auch schon mal ein gutes Zeichen. Und die verschiedenen Theorien, die es da gibt, die zeichnen sich gerne dadurch aus, dass sie in der Realität nicht falsifizierbar sind. Also man kann die mal ausprobieren und das geschieht auch gelegentlich. Aber wenn irgendwas nicht geht, dann gibt es immer irgendeine Ausrede.
Also meistens liegt es dann daran, dass die Theorie nicht vollständig implementiert wurde.
Das ist die Hauptausrede oder es gibt noch so andere Theorien.
Oder externe Faktoren, die nicht vorhersehbar waren.
Ja, oder es gab eine Ausnahme, die nicht berücksichtigt wurde. Also es gibt immer eigentlich Ausreden. Und so gibt es wenig Theorien, die heute als komplett falsifiziert gelten, selbst wenn die Fakten gegen sie sprechen. Daher halten wir uns jetzt nicht damit auf, uns hier an irgendwelche Sachen zu halten. Und wir nehmen billigend in Kauf jetzt hier wahrscheinlich größere Teile der Establishments gegen uns aufzubringen.
Aber gut, das war schon immer unsere Idee. Also wir probieren es einfach mal mit Logik, nicht wahr?
Wir machen einfach mal und gucken, wie weit wir kommen.
Ja gut, also bevor es den Zockerkapitalismus gab, wo also mit dem Geld vorwiegend spekuliert wurde, so wie heute. Und eigentlich für die allermeisten Leute im Alltag ist Geld immer noch ein Mittel von Wertrepräsentanz, der den einfachen Austausch von Waren und Arbeit ermöglicht. Also wenn ich irgendwie mir die Haare schneiden lassen will, dann muss ich da nicht irgendwie mit, keine Ahnung, meinem selbstgedenkelten Kupferkessel hingehen, um die Haare geschnitten zu bekommen, sondern ich kann für meinen selbstgedenkelten Kupferkessel auf dem Markt Geld erhalten und mit diesem Geld kann ich dann zum Friseur gehen und mir die Haare schneiden lassen. Und dieses Zwischentauschmittel, diente halt primär dazu, dass man halt einfach nicht mehr nur zum Beispiel auch verderbliche Waren wie Lebensmittel oder ähnliche Dinge über Weiterstrecken transportieren musste, um dann auch teilweise echt Wechselgeldprobleme zu haben.
Also es gibt auch einfach Märkte, der Bauer erntet halt nicht das ganze Jahr über und nicht alle Sachen, die man ernten kann, halten dann ein Jahr lang und können abverkauft werden. Das heißt, es gibt so ganz ganz witzige Beispiele in der Karibik für irgendwelche, oder nee, das weiß ich jetzt nicht, wo das war, kann auch bei Australien gewesen sein. Also jedenfalls für so Inselgruppen, die einen zirkulären Handel treiben und wo jede Insel irgendwas herstellt, was nur in einem bestimmten Teil des Jahres überhaupt verfügbar ist. Und dann braucht man eben irgendeine Methode, wie man den Wert abbilden kann in den Zeiten, wo man gerade nichts zu ernten hat und wo man Geld, Geld wird also nicht nur benutzt, um so was abzubilden, sondern auch ums zu speichern, also um Wohlstand oder Vermögen, sagen wir mal, zu speichern. Aber es ist nur ein Symbol für den Wohlstand oder das Vermögen. Es ist nicht selbst Vermögen, sondern eigentlich ist es das Versprechen, in der Zukunft eine Dienstleistung oder Waren zu kriegen.
Naja, die Akzeptanz ist eigentlich das Versprechen, also dass man in der Lage ist, für dieses Tauschabiet Geld in der Zukunft Waren oder Dienstleistung zu bekommen. Das hat auch eine Menge praktischer Aspekte. Also wenn man zum Beispiel Kühe züchtet und nur mal einen Tee trinken will, dann will man nicht irgendwie ins Café gehen und sagen, hier schneid dir mal ein Stück von der Kuh ab für den Tee. Also Geld kann man festhalten, ist eine sehr praktische Angelegenheit. Man braucht es irgendwie, um im Alltag nicht komplett in Schwierigkeiten zu ersaufen, die dann doch sehr läherlich erscheinen.
Es gab ganz interessante Ansätze im Laufe der Menschheitsgeschichte. Es ging nicht los mit Gold und Silber, sondern es ging los mit irgendwelchen Knochenketten und Kunstobjekten im Wesentlichen. Also Objekte, die keine eigene Bedeutung haben, mit denen man nichts Sinnvolles machen kann. Es gab auch z.B. Ziehschwerte, die benutzt werden als Handelsmittel, als Geld. In China gab es wohl sogar mal irgendwelche zeremonielle Äxte, denen man halt einen Wert so zugeschrieben hat. Aber Knochen sind so eine häufige Sache. Und was man auch mal genommen hat, war Getreide, weil das halt ein Jahr lang hält und weil es klein genug quantifizierbar ist, dass man auch kleinere Käufe damit machen konnte. Aber es ist halt unhandlich, wenn man was Größeres kaufen will.
Ja gut, bei Getreide kann man es ja schon abmessen, aber hat halt den Nachteil, dass es eben doch noch relativ unhandlich ist, wenn man es in größeren Mengen über große Strecken transportieren will. Das ist verderblich, man muss aufpassen, dass die Mäuse nicht rangehen. Und natürlich bei solchen Knochensachen oder so Kunstwerken ist natürlich die Frage der Nachmachbarkeit. Also da muss ein Kunstwerk dann schon eine Menge Arbeit enthalten, die es unrealistisch machen, dass man es nachmacht. Das kann natürlich zu interessanten Rationalisierungseffekten werden.
Und die Aufteilbarkeit ist auch ein echtes Problem. Also es gibt Beispiele, dass die Stämme dann so was gemacht haben wie eine Kette aus Knochenteilchen. Und wenn man halt was bezahlen wollte, dann hat man so ein paar davon abgenommen und den Rest wieder zu einer Kette zusammengetan. Also das ist auch ein inhärentes Problem. Wenn ich jetzt sowas habe wie ein Kunstwerk, dann kann ich auch nur einen Geldbetrag damit bezahlen.
Also meistens einen größeren oder...
Genau, also die Aufteilbarkeit ist auch ein wichtiges Problem, was Geld zu lösen versucht.
Naja, und dann sind natürlich solche Sachen, die irgendwie mit, sagen wir mal, nicht universell akzeptiert waren, also irgendwelche Knochenstückchen oder dergleichen Dinge, waren natürlich spätestens dann, als es an den Fernhandel ging, problematisch, weil die Akzeptanz von solchen Sachen ist natürlich gering. Und da ist man dann doch relativ schnell bei Sachen gelandet, die universell relativ selten waren, also die es universell nicht so richtig überall gab und wo man auch nicht erwarten musste, dass es da plötzlich durch irgendeine Rationalisierungseffekte oder so, ja, da eine Inflation gibt, also dass halt plötzlich jemand Geld machen kann. Und da ist man dann halt ziemlich schnell bei Gold und Silber gelandet als Mittel des Währungsaustauschs.
Wobei sich das lustigerweise auch von selbst reguliert so ein bisschen. Also ich hab so eine witzige Geschichte gefunden, da ging es um die amerikanischen Kolonien der Briten. Und da gab es eben eine Währungsknappheit, kommen wir später noch zu, warum es die gab. Aber da haben die Kolonisten, haben dann eben von den Eingeborenen deren Zahlungssysteme übernommen, um mit denen handeln zu können. Und das waren dann so Knochenstückchen von Muscheln. Und die gibt es ja nur am Meer. Und dann hat es sich so Spezialisierung ergeben. Es gab halt einen Stamm, der war dafür zuständig, das Geld zu beschaffen. Also man kommt da schon drumherum. Und die sehen ja auch selber, dass sie sich ihren Lebensunterhalt kaputt machen, wenn es zu viel Geld gibt. Das heißt, die haben auch wieder ein Interesse daran, dafür zu sorgen, dass es dann keine Schwämme gibt.
Das heißt, da gab es dann einen Stamm, der die Geldmenge gesteuert hat.
Genau. Also wie heute gibt es auch einen Stamm, der heißt halt Zertralbank.
Und versucht die Geldmenge zu steuern. Interessant. Also Gold und Silber waren dann aber schon ziemlich bald, sobald es halt eine große Menge Fernhandel gab, eigentlich doch ein relativ beliebtes Mittel, obwohl man noch sagen muss, dass zum Beispiel Salz auch sehr lange als Währung diente, weil es eben schwierig zu beschaffen war und auch nicht so richtig in großen Mengen verfügbar war. Man hat es halt irgendwie aufwendig am Meer mit viel Handarbeit, aus dem Meer wasser Salz gemacht. Deswegen hat es halt einen Wert gehabt, der sich dann aber spätestens verflüchtigte, als es halt die ersten Salzbergwerke gab. Eine andere Sache, die mir reinfällt, ist, es gab eine kurze Zeitspanne, in der Aluminium extrem wertvoll war, weil die Energiemenge, die man zur Herstellung brauchte, halt so groß ist.
Das ist wieder am Kommen, ne? Also heute ist es auch so, dass die Aluminiumherstellung Unmengen an Energie frisst und deswegen macht man das zum Beispiel auch auf Island, wo es eben sehr billig geothermische Energie gibt. Und ich denke, das wird wieder kommen. Je teurer die fossilen Brennstoffe werden, desto teurer wird Aluminium werden, weil man es eben nicht mehr so billig herstellen kann, außer wir schaffen es halt mit irgendwie Wasser.
Ich glaube, der größte Teil von Aluminium wird heutzutage noch mit Atomenergie hergestellt, aber...
Na ja, das ist ja auch wirklich...
Na ja, gut. In Deutschland vielleicht, möglicherweise, eventuell, wenn die CDU ihren... Wie heißt es zum Teil nicht Atomausstieg, sondern...
Ist die... Doch, doch, das ist der Ausstieg.
Das ist der Ausstieg.
Wenn du die CDU fragst, ist das der Ausstieg, keine Verlängerung.
Die laufzeitverlängerung heißt jetzt Atomausstieg.
Genau.
Ja, verstehe. Na gut, also jedenfalls, wenn die laufzeitverlängerung des Ausstiegsgeschichte zu Ende ist, dann wird Aluminium vielleicht in Deutschland teurer. Glaube ich noch nicht so richtig dran. Dafür ist zu viel Aluminium unterwegs. Aber gut, aber jedenfalls ist es ein schönes Beispiel dafür, dass Sachen, die halt zwischenzeitlich mal selten sind, dann eben doch gerne als Währung benutzt werden.
Und warum eigentlich Gold und Silber? Da gibt es mehrere Gründe für. Also Gold war eines der ersten Metalle, was die Menschheit bearbeiten konnte, weil es relativ weich ist. Und es rostet nicht.
Es sieht schick aus.
Es sieht nett aus, ja, es glänzt nett. Ja, und es ist eben relativ gleichmäßig verteilt auf der Welt.
Ja, und das ist halt den großen Vorteil, dass es nicht vergeht. Also es ist halt keine vergängliche Währung, sondern die kann auch über 100 Jahre in einer rottigen Höhle liegen und ist immer noch genauso gut wie am Tag, als es da eingelabert wurde.
Genau, weil sie halt nicht rostet. Dadurch, dass es gleich verteilt ist, gibt es auch keine Ungerechtigkeit. Also naja, es ist nicht völlig gleich verteilt. Es gibt dann schon mal irgendwie so eine Goldader.
Also es gibt halt schon Gegenden, wo es mehr Gold gibt als in anderen. Und gerade bei Silber, kommen wir später noch drauf, hat es noch einen recht entscheidenden Einfluss auf Politik und den späteren Wohlstand von Gegenden gehabt. Aber naja gut, also jedenfalls mit diesem Gold konnte man natürlich allerhand Dinge tun. Also meistens hat man sie in irgendwelche Stücken gepresst oder gegossen und dann hat der jeweilige Fürst oder der jeweilige Herrscher dieser Gegend dann da sein Porträt drauf geprägt oder seine Gottheit oder jedenfalls irgendein Symbol seiner Herrschaft mit dem Ziel, dass man erkennt, dass diese Goldmünze oder dieser Goldbarren, dass es runde Münzen waren, kann es ein bisschen später dann erkannt wird, als das würde schon echt sein, weil der prägt da sein Gesicht drauf und da steht sozusagen dafür, dass der Goldgehalt dieser Münze dementsprechend was man erwartet oder der Silbergehalt. Und das natürlich dann, also wenn es so ist, dass also diese Münze genau ihren Wert in Gold enthält. Also keine Ahnung, was wir haben momentan. Also eine 33 Gramm Goldmünze müsste halt irgendwie irgendwie mittlerweile über 1000 Euro wert sein. Müsste also mit 1000 Euro geprägt sein.
Also wenn man sich ältere Agentenfilme ansieht, dann findet man gelegentlich Erwähnung vom Krügerrand, weil das war eine der letzten Währungen, wo es Münzen gab, die tatsächlich Kurantmünzen sind, so nennt man das. Wenn der Materialwert der Münze annähernd so hoch ist oder am besten genauso hoch, wie der Nennwert. Und ansonsten gibt es noch so Spezialprägungen für Sammler.
Also interessanterweise gibt es so eine kleine Bewegung seit ein paar Jahren, seit die Währungskrise richtig tobt. So eine kleine Bewegung von alternativen Goldwährungen, die so kleine, also dann halt so irgendwie 1 Gramm, 2 Gramm, 5 Gramm Stückchen als Währungseinheiten benutzen. Also die sind dann halt, keine Ahnung, irgendwie kann man sich ausrechnen, irgendwie 20, 30, 40 Euro Wert pro Währungseinheit. Fluktuiert natürlich gegenüber dem Euro mit dem Goldpreis. Aber der Versuch ist halt schon da, so was wie neue Kurantenmünzen zu schaffen, die sind dann halt so eingeprägt, also in die eingegossenen, so holographisch gesicherte Plastikkartchen. Und da ist dann halt tatsächlich dieses Stück Gold gut sichtbar drin. Und mit der entsprechenden Echterzertifikat und Versiegelung und dergleichen Dinge. Um zu versuchen, dass man halt wieder so eine Kurantenmünze produziert. Was ich eigentlich einen sehr interessanten Trend finde.
Das gibt es nicht nur bei Münzen, das gibt es auch bei der Währungsdeckung. Da gab es jetzt neulich die Meldung, dass Zimbabwe, die in den letzten Jahren eher durch ihre Hyperinflation in den Nachrichten waren, dass die jetzt keinen Bock mehr darauf haben, dass ihre Währung monatlich eine Null mehr hintendran hat und dass die gern zurück zum Goldstandard wollen. Allerdings der Weg dahin war so ein bisschen merkwürdig. Die wollten nämlich Diamanten verkaufen und das, naja.
Zum Goldstandard kommen wir ein bisschen später.
Zum Goldstandard kommen wir später. Aber es gibt an verschiedenen Fronten so einen Trend zurück dazu, dass die Währungen nicht frei wachsen oder kleiner werden können.
Nicht komplett abgekoppelt ist von irgendwelchen natürlichen Ressourcen oder so. Ja, also die Währungen, die wir heute haben, die halt keine nennenswerte Deckung mehr haben, also die Goldreserdefin...
Na, durch das Material mehr haben.
Ja, also die Zentralbanken haben ja alle noch Goldvorräte, die aber...
Was im Übrigen auch Bullshit ist, wenn wir drüber reden wollten, ja. Wenn wir gerade dabei sind, Gold hat keinen inhärenten Wert, sondern es ist genauso... Also im Grunde ist es völlig abwegig zu sagen, diese Währung ist was wert, weil wir das mit Gold decken, weil Gold genauso ein Spekulationsobjekt ist und keinen inhärenten festen Wert hat, sondern es halt auch irgendwie sieht schön aus. Da haben wir uns halt drauf geeinigt. Das heißt, letztendlich zusammenfassend muss man sagen, Geld ist Vertrauen.
Ja, das kann man so sagen.
Also Geld ist das Vertrauen, dass ich morgen mit diesem Stück Geld noch was kaufen kann, was ich dann haben möchte.
Gut, und bei Gold kann man halt sagen, ist es halt schon relativ lange so, dass man dieses Vertrauen entwickeln kann und dementsprechend ist es so ein bisschen so die, ja, also die Vertrauenswährung für immer mehr Leute in den letzten Jahren geworden.
Das ist auch so ein altes Sprichwort eigentlich, wenn man glaubt, dass es eine Krise gibt oder wenn man denkt, demnächst, oder der Wirtschaft geht es jetzt nicht gut und es geht dir demnächst wahrscheinlich noch nicht besser, dann flüchten heißt es bei den Investoren in Gold. Das wird auch gerne von Kommentatoren am Aktienmarkt dann gesagt. Dann heißt es, sie verkaufen ihre Aktien und flüchten ins Gold.
Wobei es heutzutage natürlich so ist, dass Gold eben, wie du schon sagtest, ein Spekulationsobjekt geworden ist, was halt heißt, dass der Goldpreis ja doch mehr mit dem Rest der Wirtschaft zu tun hat als mit seinem inhärenten Wert. Womit wir beim Thema sind, genau was ist denn eigentlich wert?
Wir sollten noch kurz erläutern, warum das so ist, dass der Goldwert spekuliert wird. Dann ist es nämlich so, dass da tatsächlich was dran ist, dass die Investoren ins Gold flüchten, wenn sie glaubten, eine Krise kommt und dass man daher am Goldkurs sehen konnte. Also wenn die Nachfrage nach Gold steigt, weil die Leute glauben, eine Krise kommt, dann geht der Goldkurs hoch. Und daran konnte man sehen, ob gerade eine Krise kommt oder nicht. Kann man immer noch sehen. Aber der Punkt ist, dass die Regierung da natürlich keinen Bock drauf haben, dass die Leute aufs Gold gucken. Und das ist ja so eine selbst verstärkende Angelegenheit. Wenn man sieht, der Goldkurs geht hoch, dass man denkt, oh, scheiße, das geht jetzt den Bach runter. Und deswegen haben die Regierungen angefangen, den Goldpreis zu manipulieren, indem sie halt Optionen auf Gold gekauft haben. Irgendwelche Derivate, da machen wir mal eine eigene Sendung zu den Derivaten. Aber jedenfalls der Goldkurs.
Und sie haben halt auch systematisch Gold aus ihren Vorrednern gekauft, aus den Zentralbanken.
Genau, das passiert immer noch. Da gibt es auch tolle Theorien zu.
Mittlerweile sind sie wieder bei kaufen. Mittlerweile ist es so, dass die Zentralbanken wieder Gold in größeren Mengen kaufen. Naja, die Frage, worauf beruht denn eigentlich der Wert des Geldes? Also was ist denn das Geld, das wir heute haben? Ist das so eine Theatr-Money? Also Theatr, wie die dänische Automarke?
Ja, eigentlich kommt das von Latein. Das heißt, es werde. In der Bibel heißt es, es werde Licht. Und Theatr-Geld, das heißt Theatr-Lux. Und Theatr-Geld ist halt Geld, wo auch irgendjemand gesagt hat, es werde Geld. Dieses Geld hat jetzt ein Wert. Ein Dekret hat gesagt, dieses Geld hat jetzt Wert. Und das kann halt vom König kommen oder von der Regierung oder so, aber es kommt jedenfalls nicht von dem inherenten Wert des Materials.
Genau. Das heißt, es hat nur den Wert, wenn wir alle daran glauben. Und dementsprechend ist die Durchsetzung der Akzeptanz eines Geldes eben auch eine inherentstaatliche Aufgabe. Also der Staat muss dafür sorgen, dass sein Geld in seinem hohe Gebiet akzeptiert wird. Und also das legale Zahlungsmittel ist. Und deswegen gibt es da auch Gesetze dafür, was irgendwie das legale Zahlungsmittel in einem dagegen ist. Es hat nicht nur, so sagen wir mal, rein praktische Aspekte, dass man damit sein Brötchen kaufen kann, sondern es ist eine ganz zentrale Funktion eines Staates, dafür zu sorgen, dass sein Geld in seinem Herrschaftsgebiet auch das einzig ernsthaft akzeptiert ist. Und wenn so ein Staat es nicht schafft, das durchzusetzen, weil z.B. seine Währung zu schwach ist und die Leute dann lieber in einer ausländischen Währung traden oder gar wieder zum Warenhandel übergehen, also zum Warentausch übergehen, dann ist der Staat definitiv in einer sehr massiven Krise. Ja, wie wird denn nun eigentlich...
Also es gibt trotzdem Ansätze, kann man vielleicht sagen, um da wieder rauszukommen. Ja, also eine traditionelle Lösung war, dass der Staat seine eigene Währung eben ansagen will, den Dollar gekoppelt hat. Und dann hat man keinen Vorteil, wenn man im Dollar tradet gegenüber der Traditionswährung. Also das ist so ein, was man dann halt machen kann, wenn man verzweifelt ist. Aber letztendlich ist das, hat der Staat, das ist so die Hauptsouveränitätsfunktion eines Staates, ist dafür zu sorgen, dass die Währung, die offizielle Währung tatsächlich überall akzeptiert wird. Dass keiner sagt, oh dem vertraue ich aber nicht, ich will lieber in Gold bezahlt werden.
Früher war es ja so, dass die Währung, das in den meisten Staaten immer noch sagten, dass man in Gold bezahlt werden konnte. Also er stand dann drauf, dem Einbringer wird dieser Note, wird bei der Zentralbank so und so viel Gold ausgezahlt, je nach Wunsch. Das ist dann so über die Zeit natürlich geschwunden, mit dem Goldstanderkommen ein bisschen später drauf. Aber lass uns mal zurückkommen zu diesem, was ist dann eigentlich dieser Wert? Also was ist eigentlich der Wert, der hinter so einem Geld steht? Weil die momentane Theorie von Geld, die allgemein akzeptiert ist, dieses und der fiat money, also dieses Werte, Geld. Und das sagt ja, dass das Geld gedeckt ist von dem Wert der Volkswirtschaft, für das es gilt. Also das ist halt alle Werte, die wir so haben.
Ja, das ist so die Interpretation. Also das steht, glaube ich, nirgendwo tatsächlich. Das ist so, aber so sagt man halt immer.
So ist die Theorie. Und die Frage ist dann tatsächlich, was ist dann eigentlich der Wert? Also wie schaffen wir dann eigentlich Wert? Ist dann...
Na und wie misst man den?
Und wie misst man den? Und der, wenn man mal ganz zurückgeht und versucht, alles, was einen Mehrwert, also sozusagen was hinzukommt zu dem, was schon ist, dann gibt es eigentlich nur zwei Sachen, die das wirklich bewirken. Das eine ist halt Ressourcenextraktion, also Ölpumpen, Kohle fordern, Erz fordern und irgendwie zu Material machen. Und das andere ist...
Na oder halt der Bauer auf dem Feld, oder Solarenergie, würde man auch dazu zählen.
Ja, genau. Und Ressourcenextraktion. Aber Ressourcen extrahieren und in menschlich nutzbare Formen umwandeln. Und zwar durch physische Arbeit. Also durch die Arbeit, egal ob von Mensch oder Maschine, durch tatsächlich Bewegungsenergie und Organisation, die dazu führt, dass irgendwie Entropie verringert wird. Um es mal auf einander zu bringen.
Also worauf wir hinaus wollen, so reines Geld hin und her schieben, von links nach rechts, was irgendwie Spekulanten und Banken und Fonds gerne tun, das ist keine Wertsteigerung.
Genau, da ist hinterher, also man kann es immer so vorstellen, stellen wir uns mal vor, das Geld wäre weg. Also von heute auf morgen wäre alles Geld, was wir haben, weg.
Geld ist halt kein Rohstoff, sondern ein Symbol. Das heißt, wenn ich das Symbol kopiere, deine Zeug, oder mehr Symbole schaffe, dann habe ich da nicht mehr Wert mit geschaffen. Ja, es geht um den Wert dahinter und nicht das Geld. Das ist ein Unterschied, den man verstehen muss, um den Rest zu verstehen. Wert ist nur...
Wert ist eben alles, was noch da ist, wenn das Geld weg wäre. Kann man sich ganz einfach so... Also was wäre, wenn morgens Geld weg ist, so was ist denn noch da? So, dann sind die Maschinen da, die Menschen sind da, das Wissen ist da, die Häuser sind da, das Land ist noch da.
Die Bildung hoffentlich.
Ja, wie gesagt, das Wissen und die Bildung möglicherweise, also die Fähigkeiten der Menschen, das sind tatsächlich Werte, aber die kann man wieder teilen in vergängliche und unvergängliche Werte. Aber alles, was irgendwie nur Kredite, Dienstleistungen, Vereinbarungen über Rückzahlungen und solche Sachen sind, sind eigentlich keine ernsthaften Werte. Und nun ist es aber so, dass die Bewertung einer Volkswirtschaft heutzutage eben sehr gerne über diese virtuellen Dinge, also über zum Beispiel Dienstleistungen im Finanzsektor vorgenommen wird. Also wenn man sich so anguckt, zum Beispiel die Produktivität in Großbritannien ist ja in den letzten Jahren erstaunlich gestiegen. Also hat da immer riesige Fortschritte gemacht.
Na ja, sagen wir mal so, Dienstleistung ist nicht so einfach. Also uns ist nicht so leicht machen. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel einen Zeitarbeiter nehme und der auf meinem Feld irgendwie bestellt, dann schafft der schon Werte. Aber das ist nicht an sich ein Wert.
Dienstleistungen muss man unterteilen eben in solche, die tatsächlich einen Wert schaffen und solche, die nur darin bestehen, dass jemand zum Beispiel irgendwie Bits von A nach B schiebt.
Genau, wir wollen jetzt die Banker bashen. Uns geht es nicht darum, den Feldarbeiter zu bashen.
Nee, also Leute, die tatsächlich Arbeit tun und sei es auch nur irgendwie Haare schneiden, die schaffen halt tatsächlich einen Wert. Aber Leute, die tatsächlich nur, ja, sich Konstrukte ausdenken, mit denen irgendwie Geld von A nach B geschoben wird, mit denen man Steuern sparen kann, die schaffen keinen Wert. Aber interessanterweise wurde in den letzten Jahren genau diese Art von Arbeit immer mit einbezogen, zum Beispiel in die Berechnung von Produktivitätssteigerungen. Und Produktivität ist ja die Frage, also wie viel kommt hinten raus, bei welchem Einsatz? Und das ist ganz interessant, wenn man sich mal so anguckt, wie es früher war. Früher wurde Produktivität, also die Basismessgröße für Produktivität war, wie viel pro Hektar konnte man ernten? Also wie viel kam dahin raus?
Sollte er erzählen, dass man nach Hektar misst.
Na gut, aber Landwirtschaft war der einzige nennenswerte Produktionszweck vor 2000 Jahren. So und dann ein bisschen später wurde die Produktivität gemessen, in wie viel Menschen muss ich denn dafür einsetzen? Also was ist der Output pro Mensch, den man da einsetzt? Und heute wird eigentlich nur noch gemessen pro eingesetztes Kapital.
Und den Mensch minimiert man runter, wenn es geht.
Der Mensch ist ja sozusagen etwas, was man mit Kapital kaufen kann. Das heißt also der Einsatz heutzutage, also die Produktivität wird heute gemessen, wie viel mehr Kapital kommt heraus pro eingesetztem Kapital. Und die Frage ist halt, wie lange es noch so weitergeht. Ich glaube nicht mehr so sehr lange.
Na es teilt sich ja schon ab, dass wir anfangen CO2-Trades zu machen und zu limitieren und dass wir bald Emissionspapiere tauschen und dass wir dann eher dann auch messen, wie viel umweltverschmutzung mussten wir machen, um das zu produzieren.
Wobei ich glaube, dass die umweltverschmutzung eher zweitrangig ist. Ich denke, es wird eher auf die primär fossilen Energieeinsatzgröße hinauslaufen. Also wie viel Erdöl, wie viel Kohle.
Ja, das kriegst du ja nicht durchgesetzt. Deswegen musst du über den Umweltschutz gehen erstmal, damit es überhaupt irgendwie populär und sofort kriegt.
Ich denke, es wird schlicht und ergreifend über den Preis passieren. Also der Ölpreis wird sich ja entsprechend entwickeln und dementsprechend wird die, und mit immer mehr Schwierigkeiten des Heranschafts behaftet sein. Und hingegen, wenn Solarenergie, also elektrische Energie vor Ort Problems verfügbar ist, dann wird die Frage, wie viel Barrel Öl pro Output-Einheit in der Volkswirtschaft anfällt, die entscheidende sein wird und wie nahe wie viele Menschen oder wie viele Hektar dabei benötigt werden.
Was ja schon historisch gesehen gelegentlich der Fall war, also im Dritten Reich gab es ja auch Ölknappheit und da ist das durchaus ein Kriterium gewesen für die Produktion. Wie viel Öl hat man oder geht das auch mit Kohle? Also das sind alles keine neuen Ideen, die wir hier äußern.
Na, die DDR war doch so eine. Na gut, also die haben ja, wenn man sich so die Wirtschaftsliteratur anguckt, in den letzten Jahren teilweise dramatische Produktivitätszuwächse.
Na ja, sagen wir mal nicht die Literatur, sondern die Medien, was so gefeiert wird als der Fortschritt.
Gut, ja, aber auch schon durchaus das, was man da so wissenschaftlich nennt.
Ja, aber die haben das doch erfunden. Du kannst ja nicht erwarten, dass die da irgendwie anders drinnen sind.
Worauf wir hinauswollen, dass viel von diesen Produktivitätssteigerungen waren halt Finanzprodukte und Derivate. Die machen wir in einer nächsten Sendung. Aber eben auch eine Menge Effizienzsteigerungen durch Kompetenzierung und Organisierungsverbesserung und Digitalisierung, die sich eben auf Dienstleistungen bezogen, die eben keinen physischen Wert schaffen, also keine ernsthaften Werte schaffen, die auch noch da sind, wenn das Geld weg ist. So werden zum Beispiel auch bei diesen Produktivitätszuwechsen und diesen sonstigen Umwechseln zum Beispiel Werbeumsätze mitgezählt. Werbung ist ja so eine sinnlose Dienstleistung überhaupt. Die also keinen irgendwie gearteten Mehrwert schafft, also nur dazu führt, dass Leute sinnlose Produkte kaufen, die sie sowieso nicht brauchen, um Leute zu beeindrucken, die ihnen eigentlich total egal sind.
Man darf das nicht einfach pauschal, also die Werbung natürlich schon, aber den Punkt davor, das kommt auf den Blickwinkel an. Also wenn man, wie wir, da einfach von draußen drauf guckt jetzt, dann sieht das so aus, aber wenn man Regierung ist, dann hat man noch andere Sachen, auf die man achtet. Dann geht es vor allem darum, Arbeitsplätze zu schaffen. Und natürlich rechnen die dann die Werber und irgendwelche sinnlosen Dienstleistungen mit. Rechnen sie nicht nur mit, sondern optimieren das Steuersystem und das Geldsystem darauf, dass du einen Anreiz hast, das Geld auszugeben vor dem Ende des Fiskaljahres. Weil du sonst Gewerbesteuer drauf zahlen musst. Der Anreiz, den unser System schafft, ist ja genau andersherum. Da geht es ja nicht darum, Werte zu schaffen, sondern es geht darum, möglichst das Geld in Umlauf zu halten. Und warum das so ist, da kommen wir auch gleich noch drauf. Es folgen auch häufig sehr interessante Kreisläufe aus diesen Sachen, die wir hier aufzählen. Also zum Beispiel, wenn man anfängt, bei der Wertentwicklung drauf zu gucken, dann stellt man fest, dass da auch spekuliert wird dann. Dass man sagt, zukünftige Wertentwicklungen sind auch eine Sache an sich. Also wenn man anfängt zu sagen, eine Firma, die sich gut entwickelt, der kann man Geld leihen, dann geht es eben nicht nur um die bisherige Wertentwicklung, sondern es geht um die erwartete Wertentwicklung und so was kann dann plötzlich als Sicherheit hinterlegt werden oder fließt in die Bewertung ein. Das heißt, selbst wenn wir jetzt sagen, und sollte es um die Wertentwicklung gehen, dann gibt es eben so Effekte, wie dass die Beteiligten ein Interesse daran haben, die Zahlen falsch darzustellen. Denn wenn eine Firma das schafft, das so darzustellen, als hätte sie in Zukunft eine hohe Wertentwicklung zu erwarten und das den Ratingagenturen verkauft, dann sagen die, ja, denen kann man Geld leihen und dann sinkt das Risiko, dass die Bank sieht, um den Geld zu leihen. Und deswegen haben alle Beteiligten an der Stelle ein Interesse daran, die Zahlen falsch darzustellen. Das heißt, die Bewertung ist überhaupt nicht so einfach an der Stelle, wie wir das jetzt hier darstellen. Das muss man im Hinterkopf behalten.
Dafür sind dann diese ganzen Analysten da, die diesen Unsinn reden. Gut, anderes Thema. Ja, wie gesagt, früher hatten wir goldgedecktes Geld. Die Geldenmenge.
Ja, früher hatten wir direkt Gold. So, dann kam der nächste Schritt, dass man gesagt hat, das Gold, das wiegt ja was. Das will ich eigentlich nicht durch die Gegend tragen, sondern das tue ich in den Bankbunker. Und stattdessen gibt mir die Bank eine sogenannte Banknote. Das war halt so ein Stück Papier, da steht drauf, der Mann hat einen Kilo, da gab es noch den Bankbrief dazwischen.
Vor allem gab es dazwischen noch tatsächlich Münzen, deren Gold- und Silbergehalt eben nicht mehr ihrem Wert entsprach, aber zumindest zum Teil noch.
Erzähl doch mal die Anekdote mit der Gravierung.
Genau, ihr kennt ja, wenn ihr euch so mal Euro-Stücke anguckt, die haben am Rand so einen Geriffel und auch zum Beispiel noch so eine Eimprägung von Buchstaben und so. Und die waren ursprünglich dazu da, dass man erkennen konnte, ob von einer Münze was abgeknapst wurde. Und zwar war es so, dass Münzen, die halt noch einen Metallwert enthielten, also Silber oder Goldwert enthielten, dass die häufiger kleiner gemacht wurden. Da hat man am Rand einfach so ein bisschen abgeknibbelt, so und wenn man das halt von genügend vielen Münzen gemacht hat, hat man eine ganze Menge Gold und Silber gehabt, die sozusagen einfach nur, ja, neue Münzen draus machen oder sonst wie verkaufen. Und um das zu verhindern, um sozusagen zu zeigen, dass diese Münze noch irgendwie vollständig ist, hat man halt dann angefangen, in den Rand diese Rendelprägung zu machen, dieses kleines Zahnrad, meistens auch in einer Schrift drunter. Und dann gab es aber wiederum Münzen, die waren darauf ausgelegt, dass man sie teilte. Also diese Pieces of Eight zum Beispiel, die wurden halt dann tatsächlich auch in...
Die kennt man eigentlich von Monkey Island hauptsächlich und von Piratenfilmen.
Ja zum Beispiel. Und die wurden halt zum Beispiel auch dann halt gehackt. Also die wurden halt also klein gehackt und dann entsprechend hat man sich Kleingeld halt mit dem Hackeballchen gemacht. Und dieser Übergang halt war halt fließend und gab immer wieder Um Münzungen. Also meistens war es ja so, dass die Münzen wurden dann von jeweiligen Fürsten der lokalen Herrscher rausgegeben. Und wenn der halt mal Geld brauchte, dann hat der halt häufiger mal Um Münzungen gemacht. Das heißt, dann hat er alles Geld eingesammelt und hat neues Geld ausgegeben. Und in dem neuen Geld war dann meistens der Silber- oder Goldgehalt geringer. Und da hat er gesagt, ne, also die alten Münzen mit zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, dem irgendwie Portrait vom Urgroßvater, die gelten halt nicht mehr, müssen abgegeben werden, was dann meistens dazu führt, dass die Leute dieses Geld ins Ausland mitnehmen. Also was meistens ja dann nur irgendwie zwei Täter weiter war, ins nächste Fürstentum, wo die dann aufgrund ihres häufig dann hohen Wertgehalts, oder vergleichsweise hohen Wertgehalts, gerne genommen wurden. Und das führt halt dazu, dass über viele Jahrhunderte, gerade in Europa, die Portmonees echt wild aussahen. Also wenn man so mit Archäologen redet, die halt so mal irgendwie zum Beispiel auch so Börsen von irgendwelchen Fernhändlern oder so finden, die hatten dann da teilweise zwei Dutzend verschiedene Münzen drin. Also so Währungen, die halt von irgendwelchen Fürstentümern kamen. Und dann gab es natürlich welche Währungen, die waren halt stabiler, also wo dann zum Beispiel auch mehr Wohlstand in dem Fürstentum war und der Fürst es halt nicht nötig hatte, seine Währung häufiger zu entwerten, indem er sie umgemünzt hat. Und die waren natürlich dann gerade für den Fernhandel von höherer Bedeutung, weil man sich darüber im Klaren war, dass auch am Ende der sechswöchigen Reise nach Hamburg möglicherweise das Geld heute noch so viel wert ist, wie es halt mal geplant war.
Also wenn man noch dringender Wert Geld braucht, dann gab es auch teilweise verzweifelte Versuche, Fiat-Geld einzuführen, wie wir es heute haben. Da haben dann, also wenn man bei Wikipedia Fiat-Geld guckt, da gibt es so ganz lustige Anekdoten von irgendwelchen Königen oder Herrschern, denen halt nach ihrem exzessiven Lebensstil die Kohle ausgegangen war und die dann halt gesagt haben, okay, ab jetzt, also jetzt sage ich mal Papiergeld, auch wenn es dann halt wahrscheinlich nicht Papiergeld, sondern schon noch Münzen waren, aber halt ohne tatsächlichen Wert und das ist nie, hat nie lange überlebt. Wir kommen später dazu, warum wir das heute haben, denn der Übergang war auch nicht ganz problemfrei. Aber der Punkt ist halt, dass die dann auch durchaus drakonische Trafen verhängt haben und gesagt haben, wer das nicht anerkennt, dem wird geführt halt. Und selbst wenn man sowas gemacht hat, ist das mit dem Fiat Geld, hat nicht lange überlebt. Also wenn der Herrscher spätestens tot war, dann ist er nie wieder zurückgegangen.
Drakonische Strafen gab es übrigens auch für Falschmünzer. Also Falschmünzerei war in der Regel eines der am härtesten bestraften Vergehen überhaupt über viele Jahrhunderte. Also sowas zur Illustration, so die typische Strafe für Falschmünzerei in vielen Hansestädten. Ich glaube, es waren Hansestädte. Da wurde der Falschmünzer an den Armen aufgehängt über einem Fass. In diesem Fass wurde Siedendes Öl zum Sieden gebracht. Und dann wurde der Falschmünzer da ganz langsam hineingelassen unter gelegentlicher Weckung aus der Ohnmacht durch irgendwie Überschütten von kaltem Wasser. Ja, also man wollte dann auch sehr deutlich und klar machen, dass Falschmünzen kein Gelderwerb ist, den man sich widmen sollte. Also genau gesagt wollten sie halt sich das Geld drucken, natürlich nicht aus Daten nehmen lassen.
Das geht immer um Monopole halt. Na gut, aber kommen wir zurück zu dem Papiergeld. Das hat sich schon angefangen zu etablieren. Und die ersten Versionen davon waren so Schuldscheine und Bankbriefe, was im Grunde so was ist wie, der hat Kredite, er ist vertrauenswürdig. Mit freundlichen Grüßen, Bankso und so.
Destin hat zu seiner Bank gegangen, der Kaufmann zum Beispiel hat gesagt, hier, ich zahle hier gerade mal 500 Gramm Gold ein und schreib mir mal einen Brief darüber. Und wenn ich irgendwie in Venedig ankomme, dann gehe ich zu eurer Korrespondenzbank und lege ihr diesen Brief vor. Und die kennt mich und weiß, dass sie mir dann auf dieses Geld Gold auszahlen kann.
So eine Art Bürgschaft, ne?
Ja, schon, ja, so mittelding zwischen einer Bürgschaft und einer Kreditkarte. Na gut. Also man hat dann tatsächlich auch Bargeld dafür bekommen auf der anderen Seite. Also häufig genug dann halt eben auch, indem man nicht selber hingegangen ist, sondern halt die Bank ist halt untereinander gesettelt hat und man das Geld dann direkt an den zum Beispiel Handelspartner ausgegeben hat. Also gibt es auch heute noch, wenn man also so internationale Handel treibt, gibt es so ein Vehikel, das nennt sich Letter of Credit. Das funktioniert so ähnlich, also da zahlt man halt sein Geld bei seiner Bank ein, zum Beispiel in Deutschland. Und wenn man irgendwie was, keine Ahnung, irgendwie Timbuktu kaufen will und dann geht die Bank hier in Deutschland, schreibt einem dann einen Brief und der sagt, dem schickt man dann zu seinem Handelspartner Timbuktu, der geht damit zu seiner Bank, dann unterhalten sich die Banken und die Bank hier sagt zu der Bank in Timbuktu, der hat hier ziemlich viel Geld und ist auf der Bank und auf dem Konto, wo er was nicht abheben kann, also was sozusagen gespart ist, nicht auf dem Konto. Und dann sagt die Bank in Timbuktu alles klar und zahlt dem Handelspartner, zum Beispiel von dem ich gerade Kokosnüsse kaufen möchte, das Geld aus. Und dann sagt die Bank hier, zum Beispiel, Kokosnüsse sind gekauft. Meistens gibt es so eine 50-50-Teilung, wenn der die Kokosnüsse los schickt, gibt es 50 Prozent. Wenn sie hier ankommen, gibt es 50 Prozent. Und dann zahlt die Bank hier an die Bank in Timbuktu das Geld aus. Aber erst wenn ich bestätigt habe, dass die Kokosnüsse unterwegs sind. Und so ähnlich, also das ist halt ein einfaches Prinzip, da gibt es auch komplexere mit noch zwischen geschalteten Krediten und diesen ganzen Dingen.
Na und mit Staaten, staatlicher Bürgschaft dafür.
Genau.
Das ist eines der wichtigsten Instrumente, damit es überhaupt zu länderübergreifendem Handel kam.
Genau, Kreditausfallbürgschaften, die dafür sorgten, dass wenn dieses Prinzip mit dem Leiter auf Kredits schief ging, dass dann einer da war, der das Geld ausgezahlt hat. Die ersten, die sich damit so richtig etabliert haben, war unter anderem der Templarorden, der de facto die erste internationale Bank war, von der wir so wissen. Was die gemacht haben, ist, die haben den Rittern, die ins heilige Land nach Jerusalem, gelobte Land nach Jerusalem gezogen sind, haben sie gesagt, okay, ihr braucht eure Kohle nicht als Bargäck mit schleppen auf diese lange, gefährliche Reise. Zahlt ihn mal hier bei einer unserer Komptureien ein. Und dann bekommt er einen Brief und wenn er in Jerusalem ankommt oder irgendwo zwischendurch, dann legt er den Brief vor und dann bekommt er eure Kohle.
Natürlich schlau, wenn man weiß, dass nur die Hälfte überhaupt ankommt.
Ja, oder wiederkommt. Und damit haben die halt sich dann natürlich auch relativ schnell etabliert, weil als es das Thema einmal gab, haben natürlich die Händler das auch sehr gerne benutzt. Und dann dauert das auch nicht sehr lange, bis die ersten Banken zum Beispiel sich in Florenz etablierten. Das waren halt die Bankiers des Papstes.
Das war ganz witzig, weil die haben florierende Geschäfte gehabt, bis dann King Edward III aus England sich geweigert hat, seine Schulden aus dem 100-jährigen Krieg zurückzuzahlen. Und dann war Ebbe in der Kasse. Das Problem gibt es natürlich auch heute noch. Wenn Banken Großkredite vergeben und dann nicht zurückgezahlt kriegen, dann sind die halt am Ende. Mit den Bankiers war es dann auch Schluss. Bailouts gab es noch nicht. Stattdessen haben die Medici die rauchenden Trümmer übernommen. Und anderswo in Europa die Fugger. Aber die Medici kennt man halt so, den Namen als Bankerdynastie.
Wie entsteht denn nun eigentlich Geld heutzutage?
Wenn es nicht mehr durch Gold gedeckt ist, dann muss es ja durch irgendwas anderes gedeckt sein. Und die landläufige Definition ist eben, dass man sagt, es ist durch den Wert der Volkswirtschaft gedeckt, die es herausgibt. Und das Problem ist, dass dieser Wert eben schwer zu messen ist. Also natürlich gibt es irgendwie einfache Metriken, aber die sind halt rückblickend, ja. Das heißt, am Ende des Jahres kann sich immer herausstellen, dass das alles nicht so gut gelaufen ist, wie man gedacht hatte. Und dann ist das Geld plötzlich weniger wert. Schlimmer noch, es ist gar nicht so einfach, die Geldmenge überhaupt zu messen. Da kommen wir auch noch drauf. Wie misst man die überhaupt? Das ist gar nicht so einfach, wie man vielleicht denkt. Und der Wert, den man bei diesen einfachen Metrien misst, der beinhaltet eben auch allen möglichen Klumpen, den man da gar nicht drin haben will, wie irgendwelche Zockerbanken und irgendwelche Geschäfte auf irgendwelchen windigen Wettmärkten, wo man heute Börse zu sagt. Und es hat eben eine Entkopplung gegeben von der Real- und der Finanzwirtschaft. Und das führt zu Verzerrungen am Markt, sodass diese Messungen, selbst wenn man sie sauber durchführt, eben nicht den Wert der Volkswirtschaft tatsächlich abbilden, sondern da kann es zu grobendes Gepanzen kommen. Am schlimmsten war das jetzt in England. Die haben halt ein sehr etabliertes Finanzzentrum in London gemacht und da hat so viel Geld von links nach rechts und zurückgeschiebe gegeben, dass es aussah, als hätten die da irgendwie Trillionen an Umsätzen. Und es sah aus, als wenn da die Wirtschaftsmacht England und alles. Aber wenn man guckt, was da tatsächlich hergestellt wird, das ist halt so gut wie nichts mehr. Ja, also die Messung ist nicht ganz einfach. Und es kommt noch dazu, dass die Banken selbst Geld vermehren können.
Also eigentlich sind sie der Kern der Geldvermehrung?
Ja, der Geldherausgabe. Also alles Geld, was es so gibt, kommt von den Banken. Das ist ein bisschen schwierig, der Übergang, weil das nicht inhärent aus Fiat-Geld folgt, sondern es ist das Kreditgeld. Ja, ich glaube, wir haben hier noch vorher ein bisschen was. Also letztendlich ist es so, dass eine Bank dadurch, dass sie einen Kredit rausgibt und selber entscheiden kann, wie viel Deckung sie dafür hat und also mehr Kredite vergeben kann, als sie Geld in der Hinterhand hat, sondern also auch eine Bank sitzt auf einer Million Euro, dann kann sie einen Kredit über zwei Millionen rausgeben und sich den Rest eben über Einlagen von anderen Leuten beschaffen.
Na die Theorie ist ja eigentlich, dass die Banken, also so steht es ja immer in den Kinderbüchern, dass die Banken Geld nehmen. Also man geht zur Bank und zahlt da Geld ein und bekommt da Zinsen dafür. Und die Bank nimmt dieses Geld und verleiht das für mehr Zinsen. Das ist ja so die gängige Theorie. Also dass die Banken dafür sorgen, dass das Geld in den Umlauf kommt.
Naja, das Weltbild ist, das sollten wir vielleicht als erstes klären, das Geld ist eben keine feste Menge. Es ist nicht so, dass es irgendwie n Euros gibt und die Banken verschieben das nur, sondern es gibt n physische Euros, aber das ist eben nicht die tatsächliche Geldmenge, sondern eine Bank macht so Sachen wie drei Leute legen 100 Euro an und die Bank verleiht aber 500 Euro weiter.
Oder sogar noch viel mehr.
Oder noch viel mehr. Also durch so im Kreis Geschäfte kommt es eben dazu, dass die Banken Geld schaffen können, indem sie einen Kredit vergeben. Da wird also nicht nur Geld geschaffen, sondern da wird eben buchhalterisch auf der einen Seite Schulden geschaffen, auf der anderen Seite Geld in der Größenordnung. Also die Begründung dafür ist, dass mit dem Geld eben investiert wird und mit dem Investment wird Geld, wird Wert geschaffen und dadurch ist es gerechtfertigt. Und wenn in der Sekunde, wo der Kredit zurückgezahlt wird, verschwindet eben sowohl die rechte als auch die linke Seite.
Tja und die, also um es nochmal genauer zu sagen, also die Banken können nicht nur Geld verleihen, was sie als Anlagen eingenommen haben, sondern sie können auch noch Geld verleihen, was sie eigentlich gar nicht haben. Was sich zum Beispiel halt bei den Zentralbanken für fast keinerlei Zinsen borken.
Genau, also es gibt einmal einen Zentralbank oder Notenbank, Leitzins nennt man das, der wird von der Notenbank festgelegt. Und die Notenbank ist unabhängig von der Regierung, zumindest auf dem Papier. So, also das heißt, nehmen wir mal an, ich gehe jetzt zur Frankbank und nehme mir einen Kredit auf über 1000 Euro. Na ja, also letztes Mal war ich ja der Diktator.
Na gut, für 1000 Euro bist du gut.
Also ich gehe zur Frankbank und nehme 1000 Euro Kredit auf und die Frankbank gibt mir jetzt 1000 Euro und notiert in den Büchern, dass ich ihr 1000 Euro schulde. Hat mir aber noch nichts gegeben, bisher habe ich das Geld nur auf meinem Konto. Ich habe es noch nicht abgehoben. Aber die Frankbank hat jetzt ein Papier auf dem drauf steht, Fefe schuldet ihr 1000 Euro und kann damit zur Zentralbank gehen und sagen, hier, das ist eine Sicherheit.
Genau, der Typ sieht zwar nur so halb vertrauenswürdig aus, aber für 1000 Euro ist er gut.
Die Prüfung, ob ich vertrauenswürdig aussehe, macht die Frankbank, nicht die Zentralbank. Was heißt, wenn Frank nur darum geht, mit seiner Bank an Geld der Notenbank ran zu kommen, dann kann es durchaus sein, dass er mal weniger genau hinguckt bei mir. Also die Prüfung ist natürlich eigentlich in seinem besten Interesse. Das sollte man denken, dass er das Geld nur solchen Leuten gibt, bei denen er glaubt, er kriegt es auch wieder. Aber das stimmt nur bedingt. Dann kommen wir auch noch drauf. Der Punkt ist jedenfalls, die Schuldverschreibung von mir reicht, damit Frank das als Sicherheit bei der Notenbank hinterlegen kann und sich damit mehr Geld holen kann, als er als Sicherheit hinterlegt. Da gibt es nochmal einen Hebel.
Genau, und die interessante Frage ist ja, was passiert denn jetzt, wenn Fefe mit dem Geld auf die Bahamas fährt und nie wiederkommt? Und dann bleibe ich ja irgendwie auf den 1000 Euro eingesitzen.
Das ist die Begründung, warum die Bank Zinsen nimmt von Leuten, denen sie Kredite vergibt.
Genau, weil irgendwie muss ich ja dieses Risiko abfedern. Aber interessant ist ja dann, aus welchem, also Fefe ist ja vielleicht nicht der Einzige, der abhaut, sondern da können noch ein paar mehr sein. Insofern ist die Frage, wie decke ich denn jetzt dieses Risiko aus den Zinsen alleine, würde es ja nicht genügend sein. Deswegen gibt es eigentlich bei den Banken eine sogenannte Kernkapitalanforderung. Das heißt also die, also seine Eigenkapitalanforderung. Das heißt ja, die Bank muss eigentlich schon mal eine Menge Geld mitbringen, damit es überhaupt Bank sein kann. Also in Deutschland wird es geregelt über die Banklizenz. Wenn du in Deutschland eine Bank aufmachen willst, musst du erstmal 50 Millionen Euro auf den Tisch legen. Und als Vorstände musst du, glaube ich, Leute haben, die schon mal Banker waren oder so. Also da gibt es so einige...
Ja gut, aber das ist also, das kann auch jemand von da... Was haben wir für Pleitebanks? Er wurde kürzlich gekauft. Es muss niemand sein, der wirklich weiß, was er tut.
Die Größenordnung, in der die Banken halt ihr Kapital abdecken müssen, sind lustigerweise nicht besonders hoch. Also wir reden so von sowas wie so ungefähr 8 Prozent, die so eine Bank haben, was an einen Kapitalquote ist. Das heißt also, wenn sie eine Bilanzsumme von 100 Milliarden Euro hat, dann muss sie nur 8 Milliarden Euro an eigentlichem Geld rumliegen haben. Auch davon müssen nur 2 Prozent tatsächlich wirkliches Kernkapital sein, also eigenes Geld, das wirklich da ist. Der Rest können halt irgendwelche Einlagen sein oder zum Beispiel auch langfristige Verbündlichkeiten, wenn die Bank also jemand anderes Geld geliehen hat.
Also die Idee ist ja gerade, dass das Geld ist, was man tatsächlich in der Hand hat, damit man im Notfall mit dem Geld seinen Arsch retten kann. So, das Problem ist jetzt aber, dass Banken ungern Geld rumliegen haben. Die haben lieber so Papiergeld, also so Sachen wie die andere Bank schuldet mir Geld.
Genau, weil dafür gibt es ja Zinsen.
Genau, erstens gibt es dafür Zinsen und zum zweiten, wenn das beide Banken machen, dann haben beide davon Vorteile. Man sieht es eben, der eine kann es wieder als Sicherheit verwenden gegenüber irgendwelchen Sachen. Das Problem ist jetzt, wenn mehr als eine Bank zurzeit Probleme hat, dann kann es eben sein, dass diese Verbindlichkeit auch platzt, dass es so einen Domino-Effekt gibt. Daher will man eigentlich haben, dass die gesamte Deckung von hartem Eigenkapital der Bank ist. Und das ist aber nicht der Fall.
Genau, und dieses Problem, dieses gefütterten Domino-Effekt war es ja, wieso sie nach der Lehmannspleite gesagt haben, wir können nicht noch eine von den großen Banken gegen die Wand fahren lassen. Weil dann genau dieser Domino-Effekt auftritt. Also dass sie herumkommt, dass die Banken halt alle nicht genug Eigenkapital oder hartes Kernkapital haben, um im Zweifel dafür zu sorgen, dass irgendwie die Fondkredite doch noch irgendwie gecovert werden können.
Na sie haben halt gesehen, sie haben zwar Lehmann Brothers nicht gerettet, aber sie mussten den ERG retten, weil die Lehmann-Papiere versichert hatten. Das heißt, sie haben gesehen, dass dieser Domino-Effekt tatsächlich nicht nur eine Bedrohung ist, sondern ein reales Problem. Und dann haben sie gesagt, na gut, dann lass mal lieber keinem mehr pleitegehen, weil sie halt gesehen haben, also wenn wir jetzt anfangen, hier Leute pleitegehen, Banken pleitegehen zu lassen, dann bricht uns hier die halbe Wirtschaft weg.
Und eigentlich sollte es, also diese Anforderungen kommen aus einem Abkommen, das sind jetzt der Basel-2-Abkommen. Wie ihr den Namen sagt, ist schon der zweite. Und es gibt jetzt auch ein weiteres Abkommen, dieser Art, das ist der Basel-3-Abkommen. Dabei soll künftig die Anforderungen für Harpes Kernkapital auf sage und schreibe 4,5 Prozent wachsen. Also eigentlich doch eher eine Moderate.
Das ist immer noch erstaunlich wenig.
Wenn man sich so anguckt, ist es immer noch wirklich wenig. Also für irgendwie 100 Millionen Euro müssen sie nur 4,5 Millionen Euro rumliegen haben. Und die Banken sind sehr zögerlich. Die haben da allerhand gute Gründe, warum sie da eigentlich nicht so richtig ran wollen. Also gute Gründe in Anführungszeichen. Jedenfalls Basel-3 ist nicht so richtig drittes Lieblingsthema. Naja, also wir sehen, dieses Geld wird eigentlich dadurch geschöpft, dass es in Umlauf gebracht wird.
Der zentrale Punkt, den man an der Stelle verstehen muss, ist, dass der Geldschein an sich nur ein Symbol ist. Und zwar für anderes Geld, das sogenannte Kreditgeld, was von Banken geschaffen wurde. Das heißt, alles was der Staat sagt, wenn du einen Geldschein hast, alles was der Staat sagt, das die Leute müssen das annehmen. Früher hat der Staat auch zugesichert bzw. die Notenbank, dass man mit diesem Geldschein zur Notenbank geht und Gold kriegt. Das heißt, da gab es eine Zusage, dass der auch was wert ist. Heute gibt es nur noch die Zusage, dass du damit bezahlen kannst. Das heißt, der eigentliche, das was du damit, der Hintergrund hinter dem Geldschein, der kommt woanders her, nämlich von den Krediten, die die Banken gegeben haben, um das Geld zu schaffen. Und wenn man das versteht, dass es einen Unterschied zwischen dem physischen Geld und dem tatsächlichen Geld gibt, dem Kreditgeld, das nur aus Krediten kommen kann. Also es gibt keinen Pool von Geld, der einfach rumliegt und den man nur verteilt, sondern alles Geld, was wir haben, kommt ursprünglich aus einem Kredit, entweder an der Geschäftsbank oder der Zentralbank, der Notenbank an die Geschäftsbanken. Dann gibt es so ein paar interessante Überlegungen, die dann plötzlich relevant werden. Ich habe hier einen wunderbaren Satz gefunden dazu, den möchte ich mal vorlesen. Also man muss sich das so ein bisschen vorstellen wie in der Quantenmechanik. Da gibt es nämlich so Vakuumrauschen, wo spontan Teilchen und ihre Antiteilchen entstehen und sich wieder vernichten und so ist es eben auch mit Geld. Es entsteht Geld und Antigeld, also die Schulden. Und wenn die wieder zusammentreffen, dann vernichten die sich gegenseitig. Und jetzt gibt es diesen Satz, den möchte ich mal vorlesen. Da steht, insofern wird das Gemeinhen weder als sinnvoll noch wünschenswert erachtet, dass in einer Volkswirtschaft im gesamten Nennenswert Kredite getilgt werden, da sonst die Geldmenge schrumpft. Also wir haben ja gesagt, wenn Geld und Schulden aufeinandertreffen, dann löschen sie sich gegenseitig aus. Und in Folge Liquiditätsmangels die Wirtschaft geschädigt werden würde. So, dieser Satz sagt also, wenn jetzt die Leute anfangen ihre Kredite zurückzuzahlen, geht es der Wirtschaft schlecht. Liquidität, sollten wir vielleicht erklären, heißt einfach, dass es genug Geld im Umlauf gibt, dass keine Transaktionen nicht stattfinden können, weil eben kein Geld da ist. Sondern es gibt immer irgendjemanden, der das Geld leihen würde. Es kann nur sein, dass es dir nicht leidet, weil er dir nicht traut, aber es liegt nicht daran, dass es zu wenig Geld gibt. Das heißt, wenn wir darauf kommen, dass das gesamte Geld, was es irgendwo gibt, eigentlich aus Krediten kommt, dann folgt noch eine andere moralische Betrachtung, über die man mal nachdenken kann. Nämlich, dass man sagt, wenn ich eigenes Kapital habe, was ich mir nicht geliehen habe, sondern was ich verdient habe durch meine Arbeit, dann hat irgendjemand anderes einen Kredit dafür aufgenommen. Und der kann ihn nicht zurückzahlen. Irgendjemand muss immer diesen Kredit offen haben, bis ich mein Kapital abgebe, mein Vermögen. Das heißt, moralisch gesehen, ist es unmoralisch, Geld zu haben, wenn man drüber nachdenkt. Weil das heißt, irgendein anderes Schwein muss Zinsen zahlen.
Dass er denn dafür Ressourcen extrahiert.
Na trotzdem, wenn du die Ressourcen extrahierst, sind die zwar ein Wert, aber kein Geld. Das heißt, das Geld kommt erst ins Spiel, wenn sie jemand abkauft. Und der hat dann Kredit aufgenommen.
Na gut, aber da die Notenbanken das Geld ja de facto drucken kann, also die Notenbank kann ja das Geld, was sie den Geschäftsbanken leiht, durchaus drucken.
Richtig, aber normalerweise zahlt man da auch Zinsen für. Und die Geschäftsbanken legen noch mal Zinsen drauf. Und du kannst als Bürger nicht bei der Notenbank dein Geld leihen, sondern nur bei der Geschäftsbank.
Klar, damit die auch zinsen.
Das heißt, irgendjemand zahlt auf jeden Fall Zinsen. Und selbst jetzt, wo der Leitzins irgendwie sehr nahe Null ist, kriegst du ja trotzdem von deiner Bank nicht für null Prozent Geld gelegen.
Wo kämen wir denn dahin?
Ja, das geht nicht. Also das heißt, es ist unmoralisch, wenn man ein Vermögen anhäuft, und es ist unmoralisch, wenn man seine Kredite zurückzahlt. Denn wie wir gerade gelesen haben, schädigt das die Wirtschaft. Was man auch tut, ist es scheiße.
Das heißt also, das, was einem als finanzielle Vernunft nahegelegt wird, nämlich seine Kredite zurückzahlen, möglichst Krenne aufzunehmen und Vermögen anzuhäufen, ist eigentlich ein problematisches Verhalten, volkswirtschaftlich betrachtet.
Ja. Na und, was man ja als Kind gerne hört, dass wir auf Kosten der anderen leben, das wird so mit Inhalt gefüllt. Also ich glaube, ja, also ich meine, das ist ja nicht nur volkswirtschaftlich, sondern es ist ja weltweit so.
Aber es zeigt doch eigentlich, wie kaputt dieses System eigentlich ist.
Natürlich, das System ist total für den Fuß, aber es braucht eine Weile, bis man verstanden hat, wie schlimm es ist.
Ja, also die Deutsche Bank hat ja da aber irgendwie diesen schönen Slogan gehabt, eine Weile lang, bis, ich glaube, bis zur Schneider-Krise. Bis sie da dieses kleine Problem mit den Peanuts hatte. Und das lautet, der Vertrauen ist der Anfang von allem. Das Kredit ist ja sozusagen ein Vertrauen.
Es ist nicht nur inhaltlichen Vertrauen, sondern das Wort heißt Vertrauen. Also ich hab mir das von unserem Neusprechblog-Experten Martin Haase erklären lassen, Kredit heißt Vertrauen. Und wir nennen ja denjenigen, der unser Geld haben will, weil er es uns geliehen hat, der heißt ja Gläubiger. Also da ist ja Glauben drin. Das heißt, in der Nomenklatur sind die völlig ehrlich. Das hat nichts mit Wissen zu tun. Oder man kann man sich sicher sein, sondern es ist alles Vertrauen und Glauben. Das ist einfach darauf basiert das System. Geld. Ja, gut. Also wir haben jetzt gesehen, dass es kann die Wirtschaft schädigen, wenn man mit der Währung Kredite zurückzahlt. Aber tatsächlich ist es umstritten, wie viel Einfluss die Währung auf die Wirtschaft hat.
Man kann halt schon sehen in der Vergangenheit, dass große Aufschwünge in der Wirtschaft und damit auch in der Kultur kamen häufiger daher, dass es Währungszuflüsse gab, also Vermehrungen der Geldmenge, zumindest bei der Metallgedeckten Währung, also Gold- oder Silberwährung. Also zum Beispiel, als das südamerikanische Gold durch die Conquistadores hierher geschafft wurde, gab es ja einen massiven Aufschwung da in Südosteuropa, der also weit über die eigentlichen geostrategischen und geografischen Voraussetzungen dieser Länder hinausging. So ist es halt generell mit der Ausbeutung von so Kolonien oder besetzten Ländern. Also die Nazis sind ja nicht umsonst losgegangen und haben in allen Ländern, die sie besetzt haben, als allererstes erstmal die Goldreserven abgeräumt. Auch in Europa, also im zentraleren Europa, die Flussentümer, die Silberminen hatten, also die das Silber für ihre Währungen selber abbauen und fördern konnten, die hatten es natürlich relativ gut, weil die konnten sich dann halt große Armeen leisten oder auch Künstler oder Wissenschaftler. Und ja, eben ihre Währung war halt das Metall, was sie förderten. Dementsprechend groß war eben auch die Bedeutung von diesen goldenen Silberminen. Man kann aber auch sagen, dass wiederum andererseits so diese Kriege und Krisen kamen eben häufig auch, wenn es Währungsmängel oder Imbalanzen gab. So zum Beispiel der der Abfluss des europäischen Silbers nach Asien, hatten wir letztes Mal.
Die Opiumkriege. Da gibt es zumindest eine Korrelation. Also was jetzt was auslöst von den beiden ist nicht völlig klar, oder?
Ja, aber man kann sagen, dass es meistens zusammenkommt. Und vor dem zweiten Weltkrieg gab es ja auch lokale Hyperinflationen, zum Beispiel in Deutschland und massivste Wechselkursschwankungen. Und diese Kriege waren dann dementsprechend aber auch häufig der Grund für Währungsreformen.
Na ja, ob Grund oder Anlass oder wie sagt man?
Na ja, Auslöser, ja.
Ne, Vorwand. Das kommt schon auch vor, dass jemand irgendwie sagt, wir haben so viele Schulden für diesen Krieg aufnehmen müssen.
Na gut, genug war es ja auch real, dass sie einfach, also kann man schon sagen, dass Überschuldung nach Kriegen oder Zukriegen war halt häufig auch ein Grund für Ummünzung und so.
Ja, aber Überschuldung alleine führt selten zu Währungsreformen, sondern da brauchst du eigentlich fast immer noch einen Krieg, auf dem man zeigen kann, oder? Das meine ich mit Vorwand.
Na ja, ich glaube, dass...
Das wird jetzt niemand hier ernsthaft bestreiten wollen. Wir haben einen fetten Krieg geführt.
Na ja, aber so ein Krieg führt halt eh doch dazu, dass die Verschuldung in der Regel enorm zunimmt. Na klar. Also so eine Währungsreform ist ja eine interessante Sache. Also was man da tut, ist, man fasst ja dann plötzlich den Kern des Geldes an, wo man sich sonst sorgfältig drum rumdrückt. Und typischerweise werden halt bei Währungsreformen ja nicht alle Arten von Geld oder Geldvorhaltung gleichmäßig behandelt. Also typischerweise ist es so, dass Schulden meistens abgewertet werden. Irgendwie zwischen 1 zu 2 und 1 zu 10 sind sie die typischen Abwertungsgrößen.
Dafür macht man ja im Grunde die Währungsreform.
Genau, um die Schulden loszuwerden, ja. Das ist halt der wesentliche Teil. Damit die Wirtschaft aber weiter läuft, sagen wir mal, hier alle wiederkehrenden Zahlungen, also zum Beispiel Löhne und Mieten und solche Sachen.
Geldströme.
Die passieren 1 zu 1 in der Regel. Das heißt, die werden nicht angefasst, sondern werden halt 1 zu 1 so weitergeführt, wie vorher ist das die Miete, wenn sie heute 600 Euro kostet, dann wird sie später auch irgendwie 600, 9 Euro kosten.
Na gut, es kommt auch die Währungsreform an. Es kommt auch häufig vor, dass man noch ein paar Nullen streicht, wenn man schon am Reformieren ist.
Na gut, das ist ja nur eine psychologische Reform, dass man einfach sagt, okay, das wäre...
Das kommt aber schon auch zusammen, ne? Also es gibt es auch...
Ja, passiert durchaus. Also in Frankreich zum Beispiel, mit dem alten und dem neuen Franken, da haben sie halt einfach gestrichen. Interessant ist aber, dass zum Beispiel Guthaben meistens bis zum gewissen Grenzbetrag eins zu eins umgestellt werden. Das heißt also, wenn man halt Geld auf dem Konto hat, dann wird das in der Regel halt eins zu eins umgestellt. Das heißt also irgendwie, sagt man, okay, zum Beispiel bei der Umstellung von Ostmark auf Westmark wurden auch die Guthaben bis zu bestimmten Höhen, je nach Altersstrukturierung, zwischen 2000 und 5000 Mark wurden umgestellt. 6000 Mark wurden umgestellt, eins zu eins und danach eins zu zwei. Das dann zu lustigen Effekten führte, dass die Leute halt alle noch irgendwelche armen Verwandten suchten, bei denen sie noch Geld zwischen bunkern konnten auf dem Konto.
Häuflicherweise gibt es auch vor Währungsreformen eine Inflationsphase.
Ja klar.
Und in dem Zusammenhang macht es dann schon Sinn zu sagen, die drei, vier Guthaben, die überhaupt noch was wert sind, die können wir jetzt auch noch wegnehmen, die bleiben dann halt erhalten.
Klar. Und interessant ist aber, dass natürlich die Investitionen in Sachwerte, also wenn jemand vorher ein Grundstück zum Beispiel kauft oder Maschinen oder so, die verlieren ja nicht am Wert.
Wurde bemerkt, richtig kauft, nicht auf Hypotheken.
Nicht auf Hypotheken. Also Hypotheken umgerubelt werden, ist halt immer eine schwierige Frage, die halt auch in unterschiedlichen Wirkungsformen unterschiedlich gehandhabt wurde. Es gab Wirkungsformen, wo die teilweise abgewertet wurden, wie die Schulden. Dann gab es auch welche, wo die eins zu eins umgestellt wurden. Und man sagt, okay, es ist ja sozusagen ein Sachwert, den man da bekommen hat. Und der Sachwert ist ja auch hinterlegt. Das ist also die Hinterlegung der Schulden. Und dementsprechend werden die halt auch eins zu eins umgestellt. Und richtig bitter ist, dass es auch etliche Währungsreformen gab, wo zum Beispiel Dispo-Kredite, also die Kredite, die man halt so selber hat, so als Normalbürger, die wurden selbstverständlich eins zu eins umgestellt. Ja, dann ist es doch das Kapital, die haben Banken. Genau.
Und im Brauch nach den Banken.
Und nicht aber die Schulden von großen Unternehmen und so. Typischerweise ist es halt so, dass die gefolgt, also in Gefolge von solchen Währungsreformen passieren immer irgendwelche Maßnahmen, die dafür sorgen sollen, dass so eine Währungsreform Akzeptanz hat, also dass sozusagen der Erfolg offensiv präsentiert wird. Und typischerweise ist es dann so was wie Infrastrukturaufbau oder bei der Währungsreform 1948 war es so, also von der Reichsmarkt zur deutschen Mark im Westen, dass dann am nächsten Morgen halt einfach die Läden alle komplett voll waren. Mit Waren, nicht mit Menschen. Mit Waren, um halt irgendwie zu symbolisieren, dass jetzt hier mal das richtig nach vorne geht und so.
Das Geld ist was wert, da kann man auch echt was verkaufen. Würdigerweise heißt es eben, dass man Investitionen in Infrastruktur auch durchaus mal zurückhält, bis nach der Währungsreform. Das nämlich gut die Wirtschaft ankurbelt, wenn man da anfängt, Straßen zu bauen und so weiter.
Ich glaube, dass die nächste Reform sicherlich der Dollar sein wird.
Wir haben uns da vorhin darüber unterhalten. Ich habe eigentlich gesagt, ich glaube das andersrum, dass sie erst die Straßen renovieren und die Brücken bauen, weil ja die Schulden, die sie aufgenommen haben, um das zu machen, nach der Reform weniger wert sind. Aber das ist natürlich ein gutes Argument zu sagen, dass man nach der Reform was braucht, um die Wirtschaft anzukurbeln und das Vertrauen der Leute zu wenden.
Also ich denke ja, dass die nächste Reform tatsächlich der Dollar sein wird. Ein wesentlicher Schritt dabei wird sicherlich sein, dass so was wie Staatsanleihen und Auslandsguthaben eben nicht eins zu eins umgestellt werden, sondern wahrscheinlich nur die im Inland. Und die Amis haben ja ohnehin das Problem, dass zum wiederholten Male, dass eben signifikante Teile ihrer Währung, also weit überwiegende Teile ihrer Währung im Ausland sind. Und dementsprechend werden sie die vermutlich nicht eins zu eins umstellen. Sondern nur das, was sich im Inland befindet.
Also das ist auch gerade so das spannende Rennen in der Weltpolitik. Welche Währung können wir wie weit runter manipulieren? Also das Problem ist einfach, wenn ich als Deutschland meine Waren im Ausland verkaufen möchte. Zum Beispiel in den USA. Und der Wechselkurs ist ungünstig, sodass ich für einen Euro mehr als einen Dollar zahlen muss im Wechselkurs. Dann ist es für die Amerikaner teuer, meine Waren zu kaufen. Und dann ist es entsprechend schwieriger für mich, meine Waren abzusetzen und die Exporte sinken. Und das ist gerade für eine Wirtschaft wie die deutsche, die deutsche Wirtschaft, die sehr exportfixiert ist, ein echtes Problem. Das heißt, wenn die Amerikaner anfangen, ihren Dollar zu senken, den Wert des Dollars zu senken, damit ihre Schulden weniger wert werden, dann muss die Europäische Union nachziehen und den Euro senken, damit wir noch exportieren können. Weil die Amerikaner nach wie vor, also mit der EU ungefähr gleich groß, oder die EU ist ein bisschen größer, aber das sind die beiden größten Märkte auf der Welt.
Und der Euro muss natürlich auch deswegen fallen, damit die Anlagen, also sozusagen die in Dollar gehaltenen Anlagen, hinterher noch was wert sind. Also ist ja so, dass das sozusagen der, was zum Beispiel unsere Zentralbank an Dollaranleihen hält, wird natürlich entsprechend weniger wert in Euro, wenn der Kurs des Dollar gegenüber dem Euro massiv einbricht. Und dementsprechend gibt es da so einen Abwertungswertlauf. Und die, lustigerweise, diejenigen, die sich die Sache sehr entspannt angucken können, sind die Chinesen. Weil die Chinesen haben halt keine frei bewegliche Währung, sondern deren Juan ist gebunden an einen sogenannten Währungskorb. Das heißt also, die sagen halt, der Kurs unserer Währung richtet sich nach irgendwie einem Kurs von, keine Ahnung, 10 Euro, 12 Währungen, die natürlich der Dollar und der Euro sehr wichtig sind. Und wird festgelegt nach einem Misch, gemischt dieser Anteile.
Gewichtet?
Gewichtet der Anteile aus den unterschiedlichen Währungen, die wiederum gewichtet werden, entsprechend der exportvolumina. Das heißt also, China steuert offensichtlich den Inhalt dieses Währungskorbes danach, wie viel sie wohin exportieren, um halt ihren Juan entsprechend den jeweiligen Währung halt in der Balance zu halten. Und dadurch, dass es halt über so einen Korb geht, sind die Schwankungsbrandbreite relativ gering und ob jetzt die Europäer und die Amerikaner sich da einen Abwertungswettlauf liefern, ist ihnen einigermaßen herzlich egal, weil der Juan halt einfach mitfloatet.
Und es ist auch so, dass die Chinesen, die haben im Grunde nicht viel zu verlieren, denn das Geld, was sie einnehmen in ihrem Handel mit den USA, das investieren sie eigentlich nicht im Inland, sondern das fließt direkt wieder zurück in die USA, nämlich als Kredit. Das ist das chinesische Modell. Davon kaufen die, ja, aber zwei lange Jahre das Modell. Also das heißt, der Dollarberg ist noch groß. Der Dollarberg ist noch groß. Also die Frage ist, wie man darauf guckt. Ich habe neulich so eine wunderbare Adam Curtis Dokumentation gesehen, wo er das so formuliert, dass er gesagt hat, nach der Asienkrise, wann war die? Anfang der 90er, hat China die Wirtschaft so umgestellt, dass sie die amerikanische Wirtschaft managen, damit nie wieder sowas passiert. Aus einem gewissen Blickwinkel ist das richtig. Die haben einfach überlegt, was ist uns hier wichtig? Was wollen wir nie wieder haben? Ist das, dass unsere ganze Wirtschaft wegbricht, nur weil die Amis da irgendwas drum spekuliert haben? Deswegen machen wir das jetzt so, dass wir einfach sagen, bei uns ist es wichtiger, dass die Wirtschaft insgesamt rollt und wir müssen hier nicht reich werden dadurch, sondern wichtiger ist, dass die Leute hier keine Revolution machen, weil sie unzufrieden sind.
Das heißt, der Erhalt des Wirtschaftswachstums.
Deswegen pumpen wir einfach die Quote, die wir hier einnehmen, gleich zurück an die Amis. Und die kaufen damit mehr Kram aus China. Und das heißt, die Chinesen können das also relativ problemfrei aus der Ferne beobachten, wie wir uns hier einen Wettkampf leisten. Und es ist also auch nicht so, dass Euro und Dollar abstürzen werden, wenn es dann dazu kommt, dass eine Währungsform kommt, sondern einer wird zuerst umkippen und dann werden die Investoren alle zu der anderen Währung umziehen, wenn sich das abzeichnet. Und das ist der interessante Moment, welche Währung jetzt zuerst die Reform braucht. Und wir hoffen natürlich der Dollar. Also weil wir persönlich betroffen sind.
Es ist halt nicht gesagt, dass es so sein wird.
Es ist nicht betroffen, aber es ist nicht garantiert. Aber es zeichnet sich ab.
Und dann ist halt die Frage, wenn die Investoren alle zu der anderen Währung wandern, dann heißt es natürlich, dass in der Währung halt eine massive Inflation einsetzt, weil da halt natürlich massiver Kapitalzufluss da ist. Das heißt, die haben dann eine ziemlich Inlandsinflation dann da in diesem Land.
Aber es ist die neue Leitwährung, die kann sich das dann leisten.
Ich glaube, die neue Leitwährung wird eher der Johann sein, aber na gut.
Gut, man weiß es nicht, aber es ist jedenfalls spannend, das zu beobachten und man muss auch, wenn man die Nachrichten liest, muss man das so ein bisschen im Hinterkopf halten, was da im Hintergrund passiert, damit man das verstehen kann.
Diese Wechselkursschwankungen waren ja nicht immer so nach dem Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs. Es war so, dass die Länder alle massiv hoch verschuldet waren und irgendwie diese Kriegsschulden irgendwie loswerden mussten. Deswegen halt den Goldstandard abgeschafft haben für die Währung.
Goldstandard heißt, dass die Währung goldgedeckt ist?
Genau, also dass es halt einen Versprechen gab für irgendwie einen Pfund Sterling, bekommst du so und so viel Gramm Gold. Und dann gab es ein Abkommen und zwar das hört man immer wieder zwischendurch, das Abkommen von Bretton Woods.
Das ist ein Dorf in Amerika.
Da haben sich die damals für Industrienationen darauf geeinigt, dass sie ihr Fiat-Money, also ihr Glaub-an-nicht-Geld, an den Gold-Dollar gekoppelt haben. Das heißt ja gesagt, okay, die deutsche Markt bewegt sich in der Bandbreite zwischen 360 und 380 zum Gold-Dollar.
Na, sie haben überhaupt erst mal Fiat-Geld eingeführt. Das war der erste Schritt. Sie haben überhaupt Fiat-Geld eingeführt und das funktioniert nur, wenn es alle machen im Grunde, oder fast alle.
Gut, aber Fiat-Geld gab es vereinzelt halt von vorher, weil die natürlich einfach schon lange effektiv vom Goldstandard im Krieg abgewichen waren. Aber es war die offizielle Einführung von Fiat-Money, dass sie gesagt haben, okay, wir haben jetzt Geld, an das wir alle glauben. Und damit es international funktioniert, einigen wir uns darauf, wie viel D-Mark es für wie viel Dollar gibt und für Fund und dergleichen Dinge.
Ja, das Problem ist, dass ich das von Ausnehmern schwer beobachten lässt. Also wenn du im Krieg anfängst, mehr Geld zu drucken, als du tatsächlich Goldreserven hast, das sieht man ja nicht, bis die Leute tatsächlich anfangen, Gold abzuheben. Und darauf haben auch die Amerikaner lustigerweise nach Bretton Woods gesetzt und haben auch angefangen, mehr Dollar zu drucken, als sie tatsächlich Gold hatten. Ja, und haben aber als Teil des Bretton Woods-Abkommens gesagt, dass die anderen Währungen auch durch das Gold der Amerikaner gedeckt sind, dass es den Dollar gibt und die anderen Währungen den Gold-Dollar und die anderen Währungen sind daran gekoppelt. Und dann haben die anderen Länder angefangen, ihr Geld tatsächlich gegen Gold zu tauschen. Am aggressivsten waren die Franzosen. Und die sind einfach zur Federal Reserve hingegangen. Das ist die Notenbank der Amerikaner und haben gesagt, hier, so und so viel, hier ist ein paar Gold-Dollar, gib uns mal das Gold. Und nachdem die da millionenweise das Gold rausgetragen haben, konnten sich die Amerikaner das eben nicht mehr leisten, diese Gold-Kopplung zu machen und haben dann auch, Anfang der 70er war das noch 71 oder so, haben die dann auch ihren Goldstandard abgeschafft.
Interessant ist ja genau diese Herstellung aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg. Also weil die Deutschen konnten zum Beispiel, also die Nazis konnten ihren Krieg ja nicht in großem Maße über Kriegsanleihen, also dass sie der Bevölkerung Anleihen verkauft haben, dafür Geld bekommen haben, finanzieren, weil die halt schon von nach dem ersten Weltkrieg wussten, dass diese Kriegsanleihen nichts mehr wert sind. Und da gab es dann diese sogenannte geräuschlose Kriegsfinanzierung, in dem sie die Banken und Sparkassen dazu verpflichtet haben, Staatsanleihen zu zeichnen. Das heißt, die haben also sozusagen die Männer mit den Maschinenpistolen losgeschickt und haben die Banken und Sparkassen dazu gezwungen, mit dem Geld, was die Leute da reingetan haben, also was sie da gespart haben, diese Anleihen zu zeichnen. Das heißt, der interessante Effekt war, dass es keine bemerkbare Kriegsfinanzierung gab. Das heißt, die Leute wurden nicht damit genervt, irgendwie zeichnen mal Kriegsanleihen oder so, von denen sie wussten, dass es sowieso nichts wird.
Das ist ja nicht nur nerven, also bei den Amis ist es ja auch so eine Art Patriotismuskram.
In Deutschland wäre es nicht mehr gegangen so.
In Deutschland haben sie auch den Leuten gesagt, die sollen bitte sparen.
Ja, genau. Die sollen sparen und dann haben sie mit dem Geld, was die gespart haben, haben sie die Banken und Sparkassen gezwungen, Kriegsanleihen zu zeichnen. Und natürlich wird es aber dazu, dass das Geld wieder ausgegeben wird. Es wird zum Einkauf von Waffen und Kriegsmaterial benutzt. Und meistens sind diese Waffen hinterher weg. Also die werden ja vernichtet. Also der größte Teil von Waffen geht ja drauf, ist Munition und Kanonen und dergleichen Dinge. Und das heißt, das Geld ist noch da. Der Wert ist aber nicht mehr da. Also der materielle Wert wird ja im Krieg in horrenden Maße vernichtet. Und das führt natürlich zu einer Inflation. Und was sie dann getan haben, um dafür zu sorgen, dass im Inland davon nichts zu spüren war, war einen Lohn- und Preisstopp. Das heißt, also die haben administrativ verkündet, wie Löhne und Preise zu sein haben. Haben also den Markt da komplett rausgenommen.
Und das kann man auch noch als Vorteil verkaufen der eigenen Bevölkerung. Wie tun hier was gegen die? Naja, also nicht ungeschickt.
Und naja, das ging dann aber nur noch bis ungefähr Mitte 43.
Na gut, aber da war dann eh.
Und danach waren halt die meteorischen Rückschläge so hart, dass die Leute halt nicht mehr gespart haben. Und die sind da halt losgegangen und haben ihr Geld abgehoben.
Das ist der Tod des Bankensystems.
Und dann konnten die Banken dem allerdings nicht mehr ohne weiteres entsprechen. Und weil das Geld ja verliehen war und der Staat hat damit ein Militärgerät gekauft, das Militärgerät war vernichtet, bzw. verbraucht. Und dann sind sie umgestiegen natürlich auf Drucken. Also dann haben sie einfach Geld gedruckt, was die Verdeckte Inflation angekurbelt hat. Dadurch entstand der bizarre Effekt, dass die offiziellen Preise für die Sachen, die man noch bekommen hat, waren extrem niedrig. Und die Schwarzmarktpreise für die Sachen, die man dann real bezahlt hat, also für Sachen, die sozusagen im Markt waren, waren sehr hoch. Dieser Effekt setzte sich dann halt bis nach dem Krieg natürlich fort, bis dann halt irgendwie diese Bretton Woods Stabilität kam. Interessant an diesem Bretton Woods System ist natürlich, dass die, die haben, das funktioniert natürlich nur zum Beispiel in Ländern wie Großbritannien, aber auch irgendwie in Deutschland, über Kapitalkontrolle. Das heißt also internationaler Kapitalverkehr war nicht so einfach, wie man es heute kennt. Also es war so, dass man schon für größere Devisienüberweisungen brauchte man eine Genehmigung. Und da brauchte man auch einen guten Grund für. Also nicht so, dass man heute einfach da wie man...
So ein bisschen haben wir das heute auch noch als Geldwäsche gesetzt, ne?
Ja, aber der gute Grund kann halt eben sein, ich hab da irgendwie dieses fiese Derivat gekauft. Naja, und da sind wir dann bei diesem...
Ich habe einen Prinzen aus Nigeria getroffen.
Es gibt da dieses sogenannte Trilemma des Wechselkurssystems. Das ist halt auch so eine Theorie, die sagt halt, man kann halt nur eins von drei Dingen haben. Man kann entweder feste Wechselkurse haben und damit halt irgendwie eine gewisse Stabilität im System oder freien und internationalen Kapitalverkehr. Da kann man halt besser bezocken, aber auch besser investieren. Oder eine autonome Geldpolitik, das heißt die Möglichkeit, eine Währung ab- oder aufzuwerten, um den Bedürfnissen der eigenen Wirtschaft, also zum Beispiel Exportforderungen oder Importforderungen, entgegenzukommen. Die USA waren halt unter diesem Bretton Woods System die Einzigen, die dazu noch die Möglichkeit hatten, weil die konnten halt zumindest, soweit sie Gold hatten, halt auch den Dollar stocken.
Na das ist ein zweischneidiges Schwert, denn als sie im Krieg Geld brauchten, konnten sie das halt nicht einfach drucken oder sagen...
Naja, der Krieg, von dem wir jetzt reden, ist der Vietnamkrieg.
Nee, aber ich meine, im Zweiten Weltkrieg gab es halt das Problem, dass sie durch die Golddeckung des Geldes nicht einfach Geld erfinden konnten. Und deswegen mussten sie diese Bonds machen, diese Wall-Bonds. Da gibt es heute noch in Archiven, findet man so Poster, die sind, also das kann ich jedem nur empfehlen, sich das mal anzugucken. Das ist sehr witzig.
Und sie haben damals, gab es ja ein Goldbesitzverbot für Privatleute. Also die USA haben...
Ja, aus naheliegendem Grund, das soll bei der Zentralbank liegen, bitte....
die Leute verboten Geld zu besitzen, sollten sie einzahlen, haben dafür Zentralbanknoten bekommen. Ja, und geplatzt ist dieses Bretton Woods System wieder mal durch den Krieg, nämlich den Vietnamkrieg, weil die USA dann halt wirklich viel Geld brauchten, um diesen Vietnamkrieg zu finanzieren. Und das ging halt dann überhaupt nicht mehr in diesem Golddeckungssystem. Dann haben sie es halt platzen lassen. Das heißt, dann haben sie gesagt, okay, wir fangen jetzt einfach mal an zu drucken. Und parallel dazu wurde natürlich der Kapitalverkehr immer weiter liberalisiert, weil der internationale Handeln natürlich dramatisch zunahm über die Zeit. Und daraus folgte dann halt am Ende, dass diese Bretton Woods Systeme halt nicht mehr so richtig aufrecht zu halten waren. Interessant daran ist, dass die Situation eine ähnliche ist wie heute. Also die USA, deren Haupt-Exportprodukt sind halt Dollars.
Die brauchen für sinnlose Kriege, brauchen sie Geld?
Genau.
Ja, die Parallelen sind da.
Also drucken sie halt irgendwie Geld, oder irgendwie Dollars exportieren, und sie brauchen Geld halt für die Kriege. Die Zweifel in der Zahlungsfähigkeit sind heute wie damals gewachsen. Das Haushaltsbilanzdefizit ist in schwindelerregenden Höhen.
Na gut, also damals aus heutiger Sicht eher Spielkram.
Na ja, sie hatten schon damals durchaus nicht so ganz niedrige Defizitquoten. Na gut, was sie damals getan hatten, da konnten sie halt noch raus, indem sie sagten, okay, wir drucken jetzt halt einfach Geld und scheren uns nicht mehr um diesen Goldstand. Und die anderen Länder müssen halt irgendwie zusehen, wie sie klarkommen, was denn dadurch passierte, dass zum Beispiel die Bundesbank in großen Mengen Dollar gekauft hat, um zu verhindern, dass die D-Mark drastisch aufwertet. Weil nachdem das Vertrauen in die amerikanische Währung gefallen war, wollten die Leute natürlich eine stabile Währung haben. Also haben sie D-Mark gekauft. Und damit dann dadurch der Preis der D-Mark nicht durch die Decke geht und die deutschen Exporte wiederum benachteiligt werden, hat die Bundesbank dann halt Dollar gekauft, um den Kurs der D-Mark zu drücken. Und so mit solchen Spielchen funktioniert ein Wirkungs-Kurs-Anpassung heute noch.
Bis auf in der EU. Da haben wir jetzt halt den Euro, der an der Stelle ein echter Wettbewerbsnachteil ist. Weil die einzelnen Volkswirtschaften, also sowas wie Griechenland, die haben sich eben über Jahrzehnte vermieden, ihre Wirtschaft zu sanieren, indem sie einfach die Drachen immer billiger haben werden lassen. Und damit haben sie ihre Exporte konkurrenzfähig gehalten.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es wirklich so viel mit sanieren zu tun hat, sondern ich glaube, es hat auch einfach schlicht mit der...
Das ist halt schmerzhaft, wenn man da wirklich was ändern will.
Ja, naja, da ist man dann schon lieber schnell bei diesen neoliberalen Theorien, dass man irgendwie so eine Wirtschaft ankurbelt, indem man diese oder jene Reform durchführt. Ich halte es für schlauer, mal hinzugucken, was sind denn die tatsächlichen Voraussetzungen, die so ein Land hat? Und wie groß kann denn so eine Wirtschaft da eigentlich werden? Und natürlich werden solche Wirtschaften, wie zum Beispiel auch in Spanien, durch irgendwie übermäßige Kredite einfach aufgebläht über die Größe, die so ein Land einfach hergibt, an Ressourcen, an Wertschöpfung, was da passieren kann. Und da ist dann zu sagen, okay, die hätten mal ihre Wirtschaft reformieren müssen, ist vielleicht einfach auch irgendwie neoliberaler Unsinn. Und man muss vielleicht einfach sagen, okay, sie sind einfach zu groß geworden. Also die Wirtschaft des Landes ist größer geworden, als das Land eigentlich hergibt. Und reformieren bedeutet in diesem Fall halt dummerweise halt irgendwie zurückgehen auf das Niveau, was dieses Land eigentlich hergibt, an tatsächlicher Ressourcenextraktion und Arbeitsleistung.
Naja, du musst ja, das mag ja sein, aber du kannst halt andersrum sagen, dass es sicher nicht einfacher wird, zurückzugehen. Und das muss irgendwann geschehen. Und wenn du das einfach weiterlaufen lässt und die Währung nutzt, um das zu... dann wird dein Problem nur größer.
Je länger die Partie dauert, desto harter ist der Absturz, ne?
So sieht das aus.
Das kennen wir doch. Interessant ist halt, dass historisch betrachtet wird vermutlich der Zusammenbruch des aktuellen Kreditsystems, also des aktuellen Währungssystems, vermutlich mit den den Kriegen gegen Irak und Afghanistan assoziiert werden. Und also die Frage ist ja, wie ist denn eigentlich jetzt sozusagen jetzt der Ausweg aus? Damals war es ja, wir drucken jetzt einfach weiter Geld und gehen vom Goldstandard ab. Und was heute passiert, ist ja eine sehr interessante Sache, nämlich das sogenannte Quantitative Easing.
Das ist ganz interessant, damit später noch was zu...
Na, wir können es jetzt mal einbringen, aber es ist ganz interessant.
Naja, also es ist eine Frage der Geldpolitik. Also die Frage ist, nehmen wir mal an, die Regierung stellt fest, mit der Wirtschaft geht es bergab. Was machen wir denn jetzt? Ja, und da gibt es halt verschiedene Ansätze. Gibt es einmal die Idee, naja, wenn wir dafür sorgen, dass viele Sachen in den Läden stehen, dann werden die Leute das schon kaufen. Das nennt sich die Supply-Side Economics. Und es gibt die Idee, wenn man einfach dafür sorgt, dass die Leute Geld in der Tasche haben, dann werden sie schon Sachen kaufen. Das ist die Demand-Zeit Economics. Und der Lacher ist, dass keine von beiden wirklich richtig ist, sondern dass sich das nach jeder größeren Wirtschaftskrise immer hin und her geht. Also wenn man mal guckt, nach der Great Depression hat sich das geändert, dann bei dem Öl-Schock haben sie wieder zurückgewechselt. Und also so richtig wissen, was passiert, scheinen eigentlich niemand zu tun. Das ist halt ein hochkomplexes, dynamisches System. Und da hat man halt so ein paar Knöpfe, die man dann drücken kann. Und der Hauptknopf, den man hat, ist eben der Leitzins. Also wenn die Notenbank anfängt, ihren Leitzins zu senken, dann ist es für die Banken billiger, sich Geld zu leihen. Das ist die Idee. Und das können sie dann als Kredite rausgeben. Und dann können die Leute investieren. Und dann geht es der Wirtschaft wieder gut.
Genau. Also oder zum Beispiel halt auch...
Oder sie können einfach damit konsumieren. Das ist der Weg, den die Amerikaner gehen.
Oder Kriege führen.
Da wird der Konsum... Nee, nee, das ist ja... Ja, das stimmt natürlich auch. Das ist der traditionelle Weg, wie man aus einer Wirtschaftskrise rauskommt. So haben die Amerikaner die große Depressionen besiegt, indem sie einfach angefangen haben, den Zweiten Weltkrieg zu führen. Und dann haben sie halt so viel Coda ausgegeben und so viele Waffen gebaut. Das heizt natürlich auch die Wirtschaft an. Aber wenn man heute sagt, der Wirtschaft geht schlecht, dann ist ja Krieg führen nicht sofort auf der Agenda. Es mag zwar bei den Politikern sein, aber nicht in der öffentlichen Diskussion jedenfalls. Und da sagt man normalerweise, man versucht den Konsum zu stimulieren oder man versucht, die Investition zu stimulieren. Und beides heißt eben, dass man der Bevölkerung Geld gibt und ihnen entweder sagt, kauft euch mal eine Stellanlage oder man sagt, kauft euch ein 3D-Fernseher. Das ist halt der Konsum. Oder man sagt, kauft euch Aktien. Das ist dann eben Investition. Ja, Volksaktie, das war ja bei uns das Stichwort, was man da benutzt hat. Und das Problem ist, dass es eben alleine meistens nicht reicht. Also das geht zwar so ein bisschen.
Oder wenn dann nur sehr kurzfristig.
Oder ja, oder vielleicht dauert es auch mehr als zehn Jahre und es hat noch keiner lange genug durchgehalten. Das weiß man halt alles nicht. Aber es ist eben nicht so, dass man anfängt, mit Geld um sich zu werfen und dann geht es der Wirtschaft wieder gut. Sondern man kann halt so zwei, drei Indikatoren tweaken. Aber die Wirtschaft an sich, also im Moment kann man in Amerika eben beobachten, das gibt durchaus einen Aufschwung. Aber der landet halt nicht bei der Bevölkerung, sondern bei denen, die eh schon superreich waren. Und bei uns läuft es ja ähnlich ab. Also die Bevölkerung an sich sieht nicht viel von dem Aufschwung.
Also Stichwort reale Lohnsteigerung.
So, also jetzt nehmen wir mal an, die Zentralbank hat angefangen, den Leitzins zu senken. Und das lief eine Weile ganz gut. Aber jetzt läuft es wieder weniger gut. Dann senkt man den eben weiter. Das ist was traditionell passiert in solchen Situationen. Und irgendwann ist man bei 0 Prozent oder bei sehr nahe 0 Prozent. Das sind wir zum Beispiel gerade. In Amerika ist das Problem gewesen, dass die Banken, obwohl der Zinssatz bei 0 Prozent lag, trotzdem keine Kredite vergeben haben, weil sie einfach nicht den Kreditnehmern geglaubt haben, dass sie die Kohle wieder sehen.
Also die haben einfach schlicht nicht dran geglaubt, dass die Wirtschaft wieder anfangen wird zu wachsen.
Naja, jedenfalls nicht kurzfristig. Und dann ist die nächste Frage, was kann der Staat eigentlich machen, um in solchen Fällen die Wirtschaft anzukurbeln? Und da gibt es zwei Ansätze. Entweder er kann einfach selber Geld ausgeben und in die Wirtschaft pumpen. Das erhöht die Staatsquote. Da gibt es dann wieder Kommunismusgeschrei. Das Problem ist, dass der Staat gewöhnlich eh schon hochverschuldet ist. Das heißt, wenn der Staat jetzt einfach anfängt, noch mehr Geld auszugeben, dann trifft das normalerweise auf ein Defizit, was eh schon ein Problem ist. Das heißt, das ist eigentlich eine eher unpopuläre Angelegenheit. Aber man macht es halt trotzdem. Und die andere Sache ist, dass man eben anfängt, dass die Notenbank dem Staat Schatzbriefe abkauft. Ein Schatzbrief ist so was wie, wenn der Staat Schulden bei seinen Bürgern macht. Oder bei seinen Banken. Also das ist eine Schuldverschreibung, die ist zeitlich terminiert auf, sagen wir, zwei Jahre. Es gibt auch längere. Und da steht dann drauf so was wie, du gibst mir 1000 Euro und in zwei Jahren kriegst du 1200 Euro zurück oder irgendwas. Irgendeine Quote.
Das wäre ganz schön viel.
Ja, das ist zu viel.
1005 Euro.
1005 Euro ist, nee, das ist zu wenig.
1050 Euro.
Ja. Also das heißt, der Punkt ist jedenfalls, du kriegst mehr Geld zurück, als du dem Staat gewinnen hast. Aber man muss halt im Auge behalten, dass es in der Zeit noch eine Inflation gibt. Das heißt, der Staat spekuliert darauf, dass die Inflation höher ist als der Zinsvorteil, den er dir versprochen hat.
Und meistens weiß er es auch schon.
Und meistens weiß er es auch schon. Und üblicherweise läuft es auch so. Aber auf der anderen Seite hast du wenigstens eine Garantie, dass du das Geld wiederkriegst. Also außer der Staat geht Pleite in der Zwischenzeit. Aber das ist ja eher selten.
Genau. Was jetzt aber passiert ist, dass die Banken dem Staat das Geld eigentlich nicht mehr geben wollen, wie zum Beispiel bei den USA.
So, und es gibt zwei Probleme. Nehmen wir an, wir haben den Zinssatz auf 0% gesenkt. Es gibt zwei Probleme. Das erste Problem ist, dass die Banken jetzt an praktisch, nicht beliebig viel, aber an sehr viel Geld ohne Nachteile kommen. Aber wenn sie immer noch nicht den Leuten trauen, dann kann es sein, dass sie das Geld einfach in Schatzbriefe investieren. Oder es kann sein, dass sie das Geld im Ausland investieren. Was beides scheiße ist, weil es nicht das erreicht, was du haben wolltest. Und weil es dir auch noch Nachteile bringt, weil es nämlich Geld abzieht aus dem Land. So jetzt ist das Problem mit den Schatzbriefen. Oder was heißt Problem? Die eigentliche Eigenschaft der Schatzbriefe ist, dass wie viel Geld du mehr kriegst, als du geliehen hast, hängt davon ab, wie groß die Nachfrage nach den Schatzbriefen ist. Das ist so ein Mechanismus wie die Preisgestaltung. Wenn sehr viele Leute die Schatzbriefe haben wollen, dann muss man nicht viel Zinsen zahlen als Staat. Das heißt, der Aufpreis, die Zinsen hängen davon ab, wie viel Nachfrage ist. Wenn jetzt die Notenbank anfängt, in großem Stil Schatzbriefe zu kaufen, dann muss der Staat weniger Zinsen draufzahlen. Damit lohnt sich es für die Banken weniger, Schatzbriefe zu kaufen. Das war die offizielle Begründung, warum die Amerikaner angefangen haben, Quantitative Easing zu machen. Aber es ist doch Bullshit.
Es hat nicht wirklich viel zu tun. Der eigentliche Grund ist doch, dass niemand mehr die amerikanischen Staatsanleihen kaufen will. Also die Chinesen kaufen zum Beispiel keine mehr.
Die Idee kommt spannenderweise nicht von den Amerikanern, sondern von den Japanern. Die haben nämlich seit 2001 eine endlose Wirtschaftsstagnation.
Und die machen das Spiel schon länger.
Und die machen das Spiel schon länger. Die haben das erfunden.
Aber der eigentliche Grund ist tatsächlich, die Amerikaner können ihre Staatsverschuldung nicht mehr effektiv höher treiben, weil ja die Banken anfangen zu sagen so naja, vielleicht ist sie dann die Rückzahlung.
Wo hin mit dem Geld?
Nee, vor allem wie sind die Rückzahlungen aus? Also passiert die denn irgendwann tatsächlich? Und die Chinesen, die auf riesigen Mengen Dollar sitzen, haben da mittlerweile arge Zweifel.
Also das Lustige ist, dass den Japanern das über den Carry treten, die ohne geflogen ist. Also das heißt...
Moment, wir müssen erst mal noch mal zu anderen Leuten. Entschuldigung. Also was jetzt passiert ist, niemand mehr will die amerikanischen Staatsanleihen haben. Und die müssen sie aber irgendwie loswerden, weil sie ihr Haushaltsdefizit finanzieren müssen. Und...
Deficit Spending heißt es übrigens. Wenn der Staat anfängt, obwohl er ein hohes Defizit hat, trotzdem noch Geld für die Staatsquote irgendwie in die Wirtschaft zu pumpen. Und das Geld leitet sich eben über Schatzbriefe.
Ja, so. Und wenn jetzt niemand mehr diese Schatzbriefe haben will, war schon klar, dass der Staat ist total überschuldet. Und das Einzige, was da noch kommen kann, ist eine Währungsreform. Weil das ist der einzige Ausweg daraus oder eine Hyperinflation, was beides scheiße für dich ist, wenn du tatsächlich in dieser Währung den nominierten Anleihen setzt. Dann ist der Ausweg, den sie jetzt gefunden haben, sozusagen früher haben sie angefangen vom Goldstein abzugehen und einfach weiter zu drucken. Und was sie jetzt machen, ist, jetzt lassen sie halt weiter drucken, indem sie die Notenbank dazu zwingen, halt diese Staatsanleihen zu kaufen. So und der Effekt ist de facto derselbe. Nämlich halt irgendwie eine massive Auswertung, des Geldes, was der Staat sehr sicher borgt, wird entweder als Zinsen an die Banken gezahlt, von denen er sich schon Geld geborgt hat, oder tatsächlich eben ausgegeben, also für reale Sachen ausgegeben. Und der Effekt ist eben, ja praktisch, dass die Notenpresse halt irgendwie heiß läuft, dass immer mehr Geld produziert wird.
Na gut, das sagen wir immer so, aber tatsächlich wird ja nicht mehr physisches Geld gebraucht, sondern da wird halt eine Zahl hochgebretet, glaub ich.
Sondern der Zufriedenerator, der die Bits generiert. Und der Effekt ist wiederum der selbe, wie man nach dem Wettnamen kriegt, nämlich, dass die, die müssen halt irgendwie das finanzieren. Also generieren sie halt einfach mehr Geld über diesen Umweg, über die Notenbank. Und jetzt kommen wir zum Carit-Rate.
Genau, also die Japaner haben das, wie gesagt, eingeführt. Und was da passiert ist, ist, dass Investoren aus dem Ausland zur japanischen Notenbank gegangen sind und haben sich da für 0% Zinsengeld geliehen und haben damit in Neuseeland Staatsanlagen gekauft und nicht in Japan. Ja, und das heißt eben, dass die neuseeländische Wirtschaft plötzlich zu 50%– also erstmal ist die Risik nach oben gegangen– auf dem Papier, weil eben, wie gesagt, es nicht so einfach ist, die Wirtschaft zu messen. Und das waren hauptsächlich irgendwelche Spekulanten, die halt mit Geld, was sie umsonst in Japan gekriegt haben, in Neuseeland Phantominvestitionen getätigt haben. Und das ist natürlich schön für Neuseeland, bis dann irgendwann die Leute woanders eine bessere Investition finden und dann das abziehen und dann implodiert halt alles. Und das ist passiert sowohl in Neuseeland eben als auch in Japan. Und die Japaner haben natürlich nur Nachteile davon, wenn sie anderen Leuten Geld schenken und die damit in Neuseeland Profit machen und sie kriegen 0% Zinsen zurück. Also das ist klar, dass das nicht das ist, was Japan haben wollte. Das passiert auch in Amerika.
Das System würde eigentlich nur funktionieren, wenn es Kapitalkontrollen gäbe.
Lustigerweise haben die Amis dann angefangen, Steuern auf Investitionen in Neuseeland zu erheben und so ein Blödsinn.
Weil, also indirekte Kapitalkontrollen.
Also die haben überlegt, was machen wir denn da jetzt und so. Und dieses ganze Geldwäschegerät geht natürlich auch in die Richtung, dass die Regierungen keinen Bock haben, dass ihre Wirtschaft Stimulationsversuche unterlaufen werden.
Diese zwei grundsätzlichen Positionen zur Geldpolitik. Also die Politik muss den Markt steuern, ist John Maynard Keynes, der der hauptvertreter ist. Und dann gibt es noch die Wiener Schule mit, also der im wesentlichen sagt, der Markt regelt es schon. Der Staat soll sich da mal raushalten, das ist völlig August von Haig. Lustigerweise die derzeit beste Kurzrepräsentation der beiden Positionen, die wir gefunden haben, das ist ein Rapvideo auf YouTube, was wir doch verlinken werden, was die Ausländer-Setzung zwischen den beiden als einen Boxkampf darstellt. Sehr hübsch. Und ja, also die Diskussion darüber wird halt nicht enden, so jedenfalls nicht so lange, dass es diesen Kapitalismus gibt, warum jetzt welche Schule recht hat oder auch warum gerade nicht.
Richtig überzeugen hat bisher beide nicht.
Nicht so richtig, nee. Also so am Ende ist keine von beiden, hat befriedigend alle Phänomene erklären können beziehungsweise einen Ausweg aus den inherenten Problemen des derzeitigen Kapitalismus zeigen können.
Es gibt übrigens noch ein spannendes Problem, wenn man angefangen hat, Geld in den Markt zu pumpen, wie jetzt die Amis ja gerade machen und wir auch. Was ist denn, wenn der Markt sich tatsächlich erholt? Wenn die Wirtschaft sich erholt, dann hat man nämlich plötzlich, ja, dann muss das Geld auch irgendwie wieder raus aus dem Markt, sonst hat man nämlich eine Inflation, womöglich eine Hyperinflation und die wischt dann mal das gesamte Kapital weg. Also das ist alles nicht so einfach. Man kennt es ja von sich selbst. Gute Zeiten erkennt man meistens eher im Nachhinein, wenn man sie nicht mehr hat. Und so ist das auch, wenn sich der Markt erholt. Das ist nicht so einfach, das zu erkennen. Also das ist diffizil und im Grunde hat es noch keiner wirklich gelöst, was wollen wir damit sagen.
Ich fürchte, es wird sich halt so lange, es Börsen-Zockereien in diesem Umfang gibt und Währungsspekulation in diesem Umfang gibt, nicht wirklich lösen lassen, weil die am Ende ist, egal was du dir ausdenkst, da gibt es Jungs, die dann halt einfach da sich drum rumruten, um die Beschränkungen, die du dir ausdenkst und genau wie Steueroasen gibt. Die Lücken im System nutzen nur, dass es heutzutage so ist, dass die Dimensionen des Ausnutzens dieser Lücken halt so dramatisch groß sind, dass sie eben der ganze Volkswirtschaft in den Abgrund reißen können. Ja, naja, dann haben wir noch die Geldmenge. Also die Geldmenge, denkt man so, naja, es ist irgendwie alles Geld, was die Leute in den Taschen haben, aber nein, es ist ein wenig komplizierter. Es gibt auch keine einheitliche Definition der Geldmenge, sondern es gibt mehrere Definitionen. Wir haben also die typischen Geldmengen, über die man so redet, sind die Mengen M1 bis M3. Und da gibt es von allen Zentralbanken so leicht abweichende Definitionen. Die wichtigste ist halt von der Europäischen Zentralbank und von der amerikanischen Zentralbank. Und über diese Geldmengen wird ja so ein bisschen versucht festzustellen, wie geht es denn der Wirtschaft gerade, wie viel Geld muss denn im Umlauf sein, damit es keine Knappheit gibt, aber auch keine übermäßige Inflation. Und wenn diese Geldmengen steigen, muss man vielleicht ein bisschen gegensteuern mit dem Lightzins, falls also zu den Zeiten, als man mit dem Lightzins noch steuern konnte.
Eine Deflation will man auch nicht haben, ist auch furchtbar.
Also Deflation heißt, dass die Preise immer weiter sinken, was bedeutet, dass jeder, der ein bisschen klar am Kopf wird, alle möglichen Käufe aufschieben, weil eben klar ist, dass nächste Woche oder nächsten Monat oder wie auch immer, das, was man kaufen will, einfach billiger sein. Und das heißt halt, dass die Wirtschaft stagnieren wird.
Nicht nur Käufe, auch Investitionen.
Ja klar.
Und wenn Investitionen rausbleiben, dann ist die Wirtschaft am Ende.
Investitionen sind ja am Ende Käufe, wenn sie nicht in eine finanzschritt gehen. Und naja, das muss man ja mal wieder sagen. Investitionen heißt ja heutzutage, hat ja irgendwie einen schlechten Beigeschmack. Das Wort hat ja durchaus einen nicht sehr positiven Beiklang. Und ja, gut, also diese Geldmengen, wir gehen jetzt zwar nicht im Einzelnen durch. Interessant ist aber, dass die Berichte über diese Geldmengen sind ja eigentlich durchaus auch für jemanden, der sich für Volkswirtschaft interessiert, durchaus ganz wichtig. Aber die amerikanische Zentralbank hat aufgehört, 2006 eine dieser Geldmengen zu berichten. Und zwar die sogenannte Geldmenge M3. Und in dieser Geldmenge M3 sind dann so ein paar verschiedene Wertpapierbestände und Devisenbestände drin, aus denen man sehen könnte, wie groß denn diese Dollarbubble gerade eigentlich ist. Und die werden aber jetzt einfach nicht mehr berichtet.
Zum Beispiel größere Gutachten, äh, gute Arben über 100.000 Dollar fallen da nicht rein.
Oder größere übertragbare Dollar, Wertpapierbestände, also zum Beispiel.
Also größere Guthaben sind zum Beispiel, was die Fonds haben, ne?
Genau.
Und ja, gut. Also das ist nicht nur in Amerika so. Auch die Briten hatten da Einschnitte. Und witzigerweise wird sowas dann bizarst begründet. Also bei den Amis hieß es halt, naja, den M3 haben wir eh nicht benutzt für unsere Politikbegründung der Gesetze. Was ja gar nicht der Punkt war. Das hat man ja für die Bürger veröffentlicht, damit die sehen können, was passiert, nicht für die Politiker. Und jetzt ist es so eine andere Statistikbehörde, haben sie jetzt eingestellt, wegen Sparmaßnahmen. Die wollten die Statistik, das kostet ja Geld und wir müssen ja sparen.
Das war die Energie-Agentur.
Ja, aber ich meine, es ist, also die Begründung, die es da gibt, man könnte ja sehen, dass jetzt Pig-Oll da ist. Immer wieder sehr witzig.
Ja, naja, wie geht es denn jetzt weiter mit dem Geld? Also wir können absehen, es wird Währungsreformen geben. Ganz klar, investieren in Sachwerte ist sicherlich eine gute Idee, egal in welche Richtung es geht, außer es gibt eine grobe Deflation, was auch immer noch passieren kann. Momentan sieht es aber alles gerade ein bisschen inflationärer aus und dem folgt dann meistens eine Währungsreform. Also kauft euch lieber Werkzeuge und irgendwie Lötkolben und irgendwie andere Dinge, mit denen man hinterher auch noch was anfangen kann, wenn das Geld nicht da ist.
Frank und ich haben ja so ein generelles, einen Streitpunkt, würde ich mal sagen, weil ich halt glaube, Gold zu kaufen ist nicht sinnvoll. Und Frank findet Gold ist nicht völlig sinnfrei.
Ich finde Gold nicht völlig sinnfrei. Also bisher gibt es mir auch halbwegs recht. Ich fand auch Apple Aktien kaufen damals nicht sinnfrei.
Muss ich jetzt glaube ich nicht so sagen.
Mittlerweile ist es wahrscheinlich überradisch verwerflich. Ja, also die Frage ist, wo man sein Geld jetzt lässt, in welcher Form, falls man gerade noch welches hat.
Wenn man davon ausgeht, dass ihr alles den Bach runtergeht, was macht man denn dann?
Genau, und eine der interessanten Dinge, die jetzt gerade so hoch kamen, war Bitcoins.
Da haben wir eine Menge Mail zugekriegt. Erklärt uns das doch mal.
Erklärt uns das doch mal gut.
Wir sollten erst mal erklären, was generell das Problem ist. Also Bitcoin gibt vor, ein elektronisches Geldverfahren zu sein und zwar bar Geld. Und das ist eine Sache, die geht eigentlich nicht. Denn alle Sachen, die digital vorliegen, kann man kopieren. Bei Geld heißt es konkret, wenn ich eine 10-Euro-Geldschein digital habe, dann kann ich einfach dreimal mit dem bezahlen oder zweimal. Und der Typ, der mir den Geldschein gegeben habe, der kann es nur erkennen, entweder indem er sofort zur Bank geht und der Geldschein quasi als benutzt markiert wird. Und das heißt aber auch, dass wenn ich ein zweites Mal damit bezahle, dass ich als Bezahler offengelegt werden muss, damit erkannt werden kann, ob der Typ, der bezahlt hat, der es dem ich den Schein gegeben habe oder jemand anderes. Also das heißt, die Anonymität ist nicht mehr da bei dem Geld. Und die Geldscheine selbst müssen auch eine Seriennummer haben. Das heißt, da haben wir schon mal die Geld-Eigenschaften verletzt.
Die Bargeld-Eigenschaften.
Die Bargeld-Eigenschaften. Und eine andere Idee, die man haben kann, ist, dass man sagt, wenn wir das nicht haben können, dann machen wir so ein Buchhaltungsverfahren. Und das ist halt Bitcoin. Bitcoin ist eigentlich ein Verfahren zur verteilten Buchhaltung.
Gut, wir sollten noch mal ganz kurz E-Cash vorher erklären.
E-Cash ist zeitlich gesehen ein Vorgänger, ein sehr cooles Verfahren.
Von David Schaum, ja?
David Schaum, der wollte eigentlich ein Wahlverfahren machen, aber damals waren Wahlen im Internet nicht so populär. Da haben wir auch einen Teil zu beigetragen.
Heute auch immer noch nicht so populär.
Bleibt hoffentlich auch unpopulär.
Gut, aber jedenfalls, das Verfahren E-Cash ist schon relativ nah dran an digitalem Bargeld, weil er hatte halt dann eine ziemlich grundsätzliche, coole Idee.
Der hat halt eine sehr coole Krypto-Primitive gefunden. Der hat nämlich ein Verfahren gefunden, wie ich ein Stück Daten signieren kann und dann kann es die Bank signieren und dann kann man meine Signatur wieder wegnehmen, sodass am Ende ein von der Bank signiertes Stück Geld übrig bleibt.
Genau, und wenn man dieses...
Das ist geradezu genial, weil ich quasi der Bank nachweisen kann über meine Signatur, wer ich bin, aber das Stück Geld, was ich am Ende von der Bank signiert zurückkriege, da steht nicht mehr dran, dass es mein Geld ist. Das heißt, dass wir haben die Möglichkeit, so eine Art Anonymität herzustellen.
Genau, also sozusagen die Anonymität kann nur gebrochen werden, indem zum Beispiel der Käufer und die Bank kooperieren. Also halt indem zwei Parteien an dieser Dreier-Transaktion kooperieren.
Sich gegen mich verschwörern.
Dann können sie die Transaktion auflösen.
Es gibt immer noch ein Double-Spending-Problem. Deswegen werden Transaktionen sofort bei der Bank eingelöst.
Oder halt mit so einem N-NOT-of-M-Verfahren.
Nee, aber da hast du ja nicht Sicherheit, sondern eher so...
Wahrscheinlichkeit. Bei kleinen Transaktionen geht es halt, dass du halt sagst, die Kosten für die 100 Transaktionen zu fälschen, von denen du eine ausführst, sind zu groß, dass du es nicht tust.
Ja, also für Mikrotransaktionen ist das okay, wenn du irgendwie ein Zehntel Cent für eine Webseite zahlst. Dafür war es auch gedacht. Das Limit war irgendwie 200 Dollar oder so, ungerechnet.
Genau, also elektronisches Micropayment. Interessant an diesem...
An sich ein gutes Verfahren, weil es halt Patente gehabt hat.
Ja, aber die sind jetzt ausgelaufen.
Inzwischen, ja, damals halt nicht.
Deswegen...
Jetzt wäre das Fenster.
Jetzt wäre halt so das Fenster mal mit elektronischem Geld nochmal neu anzufangen. Damals war unter anderem einer der Gründe, warum es sich nicht durchgesetzt hat, dass es dann halt irgendwie 2001 war und danach war halt...
War aus mit der Bubble.
War aus mit der Bubble und es gab halt dann massive Probleme mit allem, was elektronische Geldbewegungen anging, weil dann natürlich sofort Terrorismus, Terrorismus geschrien wurde und die Banken massiv keine Interesse daran hatten. Der Staat auch keine Interesse daran hatte, dass es da irgendwie elektronisch bewegbares Geld gibt.
Schon gar anonym bewegbares Geld. Man sieht, was die heute für Zugriff auf Bankdaten haben wollen. Da kann man sich vorstellen, wie die reagieren, wenn man da mit anonymen Geld kommt.
Ja, also anonymes elektronisches Geld ist etwas, was für Staaten ein ziemlich rotes Tuch ist. Also weil es halt natürlich an ihren Steuersystemen vorbei geht, und so ein System, was im Rufe steht, anders kann man es nicht sagen, genau dieses zu tun.
Also es gab einen unsäglichen Artikel darüber, der das alles gelauncht hat und da stand drin, also Bitcoin ist ein Open Source Projekt. Und es gab einen Artikel darüber, in einem Start-up-Blobber-Magazin, wo halt drin stand, das sei ein Projekt, was in der Lage sei, ganze Länder zu revolutionieren.
Und Regierungen zu stürzen. Regierungen zu stürzen. Worum es bei Bitcoin geht, also Bitcoin ist der Versuch, eben ein elektronisches Geld zu schaffen, bei dem es keine zentrale Bankentität gibt, sondern bei dem durch ziemlich clevere Kryptographie, die ist nicht so schlecht designt, dafür gesorgt wird, dass Transaktionen innerhalb des Systems durch die anderen Teilnehmer, also peer-to-peer, zertifiziert werden. Und was eigentlich schon so als Grundidee eine gar nicht so schlechte Variante ist.
Intellektuell gesehen hochspannend. Das wollen wir überhaupt nicht in Abrede stellen. Rostografisch auch ausgesprochen spannend. Aber es ist halt kein Geldersatz. Man kann jetzt nicht statt Dollar Bitcoin nehmen.
Na zumindest nicht in großem Maßstab. Also der Bitcoin funktioniert halt so, dass alle Transaktionen allen Teilnehmern des Netzes zur Verfügung gestellt werden und die, die dann überprüfen können.
Es ist ein Buchhaltungsverfahren. Das heißt, wenn mir jemand zehn Bitcoins geben will, dann kann ich im Log-Fall nachgucken, was praktisch der Konsens im Internet ist, ob der zehn Coins auf seinem Konto hat. Und das heißt, das können alle sehen. Alle Teilnehmer an dem System können sehen, ob der gerade zehn Bitcoins hat.
Genau.
Da steht zwar nicht sein Name dran, sondern es ist so ein Krypto-Schlüssel, aber das ist natürlich trotzdem ein gutes Gefühl.
Das heißt, ich meine, es hängt davon ab, was du willst. Die Sicherheit des aktuellen Geldsystems beruht ja auch darauf, dass es nicht anonym ist. Also heutzutage ist das größte Problem, wenn du irgendjemanden erpresst, ist ja irgendwie, Geld zu kriegen.
Die Sicherheit von unserem aktuellen Geldsystem basiert darauf, dass man das Geld nicht einfach austragen kann aus dem System.
Genau, du kannst es halt immer nachvollziehen, wo die Transaktion...
Kameras in der Bank und so.
Und Bitcoin tut eigentlich genau dasselbe. Das sagt es nur nicht und es ist halt so, dass man dann natürlich ein paar Tricks machen kann.
Was ich ein Problem finde, ehrlich gesagt, wenn du sagst, du bist so was wie Geld und dann sagst du sowas irgendwie. Also sie sagen es nicht ganz nicht, sondern...
Nein, nein, sie sagen es ja schon....
die Unterlagen reden.
Also man muss halt einfach sehen, dass Bitcoin ist halt eigentlich kein, in dem Sinne, kein Bargeld. Das ist ein Buchhaltungsverfahren. Ein Buchhaltungsverfahren ist aber nur dadurch, dass es eben peer-to-peer ist, hat es, sieht es für den User so ein bisschen aus, die Bargeld, weil es halt keine zentrale Entität gibt. Und der...
Das hat Vor- und Nachteile.
Ja klar. Also der Vorteil ist natürlich, dass du zumindest eine relativ hohe Sicherheit gegen irgendwie Double-Spending aufbauen kannst.
Na und du hast keinen wahnsinnigen Diktator, der Geld nachdruckt und damit deine Geldbestände im Wert sinkt.
Du hast nur einen wahnsinnigen Erfinder, der sich die ersten 32.000 Bitcoin-Blocks gesichert hat, aber gut, dass es eben sein kann.
Es ist ein Experiment. Also es ist ein interessantes Experiment, durchaus spannend, aber ich habe kein Bitcoin-Konto. Ich werde auch keins einrichten.
Ich habe ein Bitcoin-Konto und ich habe an meinem Blog auch...
Na du hast ja auch Apple-Produkte, du zählst nicht. Du kaufst ja alles was Neues.
Nee, ich habe mir das angeguckt und hatte tatsächlich, weil ich mal noch ein bisschen Bitcoin meine, also das muss man vielleicht auch noch dazu sagen, wie Bitcoins entstehen. Bitcoins entstehen dadurch, dass man mittlerweile auch mal einen Computer mit einer dicken Grafikkarte nimmt und ein mathematisches Problem löst. Und aus diesen mathematischen Problemen, wenn das gelöst ist, entstehen dann Bitcoins. Das heißt also, Bitcoin ist eine, also die direkte Oberrechnungseinheit von Bitcoin ist eigentlich Strom und Grafikchips oder FPGAs.
Also die Schwierigkeit des zu lösenden Problems wächst mit der Anzahl der Teilnehmern. Das heißt, es ist nicht so, dass jetzt irgendwie ein einzelner Schlauffuchs genau wie am Anfang sich da gleich viel Geld meinen kann, sondern man kriegt also nicht nur wächst die Schwierigkeit, sondern man kriegt auch mit die alten Abhängigkeit davon, wie viel Bitcoins es schon gibt, kriegt man ist es eine Funktion, die immer weniger Return gibt. Also die Anzahl der Coins, die man meinen kann pro gelöste Problem geht auch runter. Und das Problem wird schwerer. Der Geldbestand ist absolut limitiert. Es gibt ein Limit, mehr als das wird es nie geben.
Zumindest in diesem jetzigen Bitcoin-System. Man kann ja problemlos mit dem Problem hingehen und das mit neuen Parametern nochmal starten und dann halt Series 2 Bitcoins machen mit derselben Software.
Dann müsste man allerdings das Geld irgendwie...
Vielleicht kann man es dann nicht oder nur über Intermediaries hin und her moveen, aber zumindest würde es funktionieren. Eine andere Sache, die halt passiert ist natürlich, dass die Leute Mixer bauen, das heißt also, um halt die Nachvollziehbarkeit von Transaktionen zu minimieren, dass man sagt, okay, man hat halt zwischen Männer oder zwischen Frauen, bei denen man Bitcoins wechselt, um zu verschleiern, dass man Bitcoins, die in einer bestimmten Transaktion erhalten, wohnen für etwas anderes ausgibt.
Was natürlich Bullshit ist. Also man muss sich halt überlegen, wenn man...
Und der Mixer groß genug ist nicht.
Wenn man in James Bond-Filmen sieht, dass sie irgendwie das Geld über Timbuktu routen, dann tun sie das nicht, weil das Routing die Verfolgung schwerer macht, sondern weil man in Timbuktu nicht auf die Bankdaten gucken kann. Das ist dasselbe Problem, was man sonst mit Traffic-Analyse im Internet zu lösen versucht. Dass man anhand der Bewegungsdaten rückverfolgt, wer jetzt was gemacht hat. Und das ist... Also ich vertraue dem nicht. Ich sollte dazu sagen, man hat mehr als einen Key. Es ist nicht nur so, dass man halt einen Schlüssel hat, sondern man hat eine Wallet, also eine Portemonnaie. Und da gehören viele Schlüssel dazu, größt noch irgendwas 100 oder so. Oder Hunderte. Also viele. Aber das Problem ist halt dadurch, dass es ein Buchhaltungssystem ist, muss ich ja immer noch das Geld von der einen Entität zu anderen transferieren, wenn ich damit was kaufen will. Oder ich muss mit N Entitäten auf einmal zahlen, wenn ich was kaufen will. Und das ist immer noch zu rückverfolgt.
Deswegen kann man sich halt einen Mixer dazwischen schalten. Oder man wandelt sein Geld halt zwischenzeitlich nochmal in Bargeld um.
Na, das kannst du aber aber von ausgehen, dass diese Übergänge zwischen dem Geldsystem die best überwacht werden, wenn die nicht direkt von den Diensten betrieben werden.
Die sind wahrscheinlich das Problem. Das habe ich hier gerade 0,36 Bitcoin habe ich schon als Spenden auf meinem Blog bekommen. Cool.
Und, wie viel kriegt man dafür?
Ich weiß nicht. So was wie 3-4 Dollar oder so. Der Kurs war heute schon ziemlich hoch. So über 10 Dollar.
Also das ist vor allem für Spekulanten geeignet. Das sollte man sagen, denn die Kurse sind derartig hochfluktuierend, dass man da mit Daytrading massive Kohle einfahren kann.
Ja, was man halt auch sagen muss, ist, dass es halt mittlerweile angefangen hat, dass Bitcoin das Level eines lustigen Experiments verlassen hat. Seitdem Leute angefangen haben, da ernsthaft Geld reinzupumpen. Also die ersten Transaktionen über mehrere 100.000 Bitcoins wurden gesehen. Und es sind dann eben auch schon Transaktionen über deutlich mehrere 100.000 Dollar, die da drinstecken. Allerdings ist es so, dass dieses System, dass eben jeder alle Transaktionen sehen kann, dazu führt, dass es unweigerlich in Skalierbarkeitsprobleme läuft. Also es führt halt dazu, dass wenn man mal, so jetzt versucht so auf die großen Ordnung eines typischen Kreditkartensystems zu skalieren, dann fallen da pro Tag für jeden Teilnehmer irgendwie so gigabyteweise Daten an an Transaktionen.
Und das ist wie gesagt verteilt, also das ist nicht nur ein Konsens, sondern jeder hat alle Daten, jeder Teilnehmer hat alle Daten. Das heißt, da fallen dann sowas wie pro Tag irgendwie ein Gigabyte pro Teilnehmer an. Und da wird es allein schon von der Netzwerkskalibrikeit ein Problem, weil nicht alle Teilnehmer in der Erste Welt sitzen werden wahrscheinlich. Was ist denn, wenn man damit in Afrika was kaufen will? Denn das ist ja gerade der Markt für sowas, dass man damit in Gegenden einkaufen kann, wo das vielleicht die Staatswährung nicht so vertrauenswürdig ist.
Ja, naja gut. Also ein anderes Problem ist halt, dass dieses Mining, also dieses Errechnen von Bitcoins, führt natürlich dazu, dass es halt ein Primärtarget für Würmer und sonstiges parasitäres Benutzen von Rechenzeit aller Art wird. Zuerst das erste JavaScript gibt es jetzt, was man einfach auf seiner Webseite einbettet und der Besucher der Webseite hat dann plötzlich irgendwie 200 Prozent CPU auf seinem Rechner und rechnet für einen selber Bitcoins. Und das kann man natürlich interessant finden, weil man sozusagen sowas ähnliches wie implizites Flatter hat.
Ich finde es sehr spannend, wie Appledorf reagiert, denn die haben ja Flash mit der Begründung runtergeworfen, dass es ihnen zu viel Rechenzeit gefressen hat.
Wie viel CPU klaut.
Genau. Und das ist ja nun dasselbe. Machen die jetzt JavaScript aus?
Interessante Frage. Also meine gut vorhin, vorgestern oder so spekulierte ein nicht gänzlich unwichtiger Wikipedianer darüber, was denn jetzt eigentlich wäre, wenn sie es bei Wikipedia einbetten würden und darüber sozusagen die Wikipedia finanzieren, dass sie halt die Atomkraftwerke wieder anschalten. Dass sie Bitcoins meinen, da müssen wir tatsächlich Atomkraftwerke, weil das genau der Punkt ist, dass wir dann halt einfach Strom direkt zu Bitcoins machen. Und das kann dann auch wirklich nicht sein. Gut, aber genug Bitcoins gebäsche. Ich denke, es ist auf jeden Fall insofern spannend, als dass es zeigt, dass die Zeit für neue innovative digitale Zahlungsverfahren ist da. Unter anderem auch deswegen, weil es halt Alternativen braucht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die da ist. Ich glaube nicht, dass die jemals da sein wird. Denn das ist die letzte echte Souveränitätsschranke, die die Regierung sich gehalten hat.
Und wenn du dir anguckst, wie sehr...
Da wären die aber ihre Nuke-Einsätze, sag ich dir. Na hallo.
Aber wie diskreditiert die Währungen gerade sind. Und wie sehr wir, wenn wir gesellschaftliche Alternativen aufbauen wollen zu den jetzigen Systemen, eigene Währungen brauchen, bei denen wir nicht abhängig davon sind, was die da tun.
Ich sage nicht, dass wir die nicht brauchen. Ich sage, dass die Amis daraus einen Kriegsgrund machen würden. Aber natürlich, weil der Dollar ist das letzte, was die haben. Hast du doch vorhin selber gesagt, die exportieren im Wesentlichen Dollar.
Das kann ja gut sein. Naja, aber das ist die größte Bedrohung, die du dir vorstellen kannst für die Regierung, dass du dann anfängst, eine Gegenwährung rauszuhängen.
Das kann man auch sehen, übrigens. Es gab ja schon so Versuche, sowas aufzubauen, irgendwie E-Gold und so. Die haben dann halt gesagt, wir haben hier irgendwie einen Goldbunker und wir geben dir sozusagen Banknoten auf dein Gold raus. Und da sind sie hingegangen und haben gesagt, hier Verstoß gegen das Geldwäsche-Gesetz und haben die Hobbs genommen.
Klar, natürlich werden sie das tun, solange sie es können. Aber die Frage ist halt, was halt passiert, wenn sie es nicht mehr können?
Na dann wirst du am Flughafen Hobbs genommen, wenn du das auf deinem Rechner hast.
Na mal gucken. Also ich meine, gut, die Frage ist halt, also Bitcoin ist halt schon so ein, natürlich so ein Kryptoanarchie-Projekt. Also zu diesem Ausgehen davon, wenn wir gute Kryptographie haben, können wir uns gegen die Regierung auch in einer Art und Weise wehren, dass sie eigentlich am Ende irrelevant werden. Das ist ja so die Ideologie dahinter, halt die alte Cypherpunk-Geschichte, die nun vermutlich ein wenig überkandidelt ist. Aber ich denke schon, dass klar ist, dass wir elektronische Währungen brauchen, also sei es für sowas wie zum Beispiel die Kulturwertmark, bei der wir nicht umsonst reingeschrieben haben, dass wir da ein digitales Micropaymentsystem brauchen dahinter, um etwas praktikabel zu machen, überhaupt Kleinstbeträge irgendwie für Inhalte zahlen zu können. Und auf der anderen Seite eben, wenn wir halt Alternativen zu den bestehenden ökonomischen Systemen aufbauen wollen, zum Beispiel durch die zentrale Strukturen oder durch die Wirtschaft, die sich mehr an dem Ressourcenverbrauch orientiert und weniger an den Kapitaleinsatzquoten, dann werden wir auch dafür Währungen brauchen. Möglicherweise sind es erstmal nur Verrechnungen oder Systeme, die halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh. Und der war unter anderem zu sagen, okay, also dieses Urübel bei dieser ganzen Sache sind eben irgendwie Kredit und Zinsen. Und wenn wir davon irgendwie wegkommen, dann können wir halt ein Geldsystem bauen, was nur sich daran orientiert, was wir für materielle, also real werthaltige Transaktionen als Tauschmittel brauchen. Und eines dieser Systeme ist das sogenannte Schwundgeldsystem, oder auch Freiwirtschaft genannt. Äh, der, äh, der Hauptbegriff dafür lautet umlaufgedeckte Währung. Und der sagte, ähm, im Kern, dass die, äh, ja, die Währung soll halt eben nur das abbilden, was tatsächlich an, an wahren und eher echten Dienstleistungen im Umlauf ist. Und um sicherzustellen, dass kein Geld in großen Mengen gehortet wird, also dass halt irgendwie dieses Zinseszinsproblem nicht entsteht, also dass halt Geld noch zu über mehr Geld wird, äh, muss es eben massive Anreize geben, dass das Geld möglichst schnell ausgegeben, also investiert in reale Sachwerte wird, in reale Dienstleistungen. Und einer der Vertreter dieser Ansicht war halt, also einer der wichtigsten war Silvio Gesell, der das so unter Schwundgeld entwickelt hat. Und da ist die Idee einfach zu sagen, okay, also auf dem Geld steht drauf, wann es weniger wert wird.
Das ist schon ein älterer Vorschlag, ne? Nee, das ist schon halt irgendwas oder so, wann war das?
Nicht die ganze Zeit, aber so ein bisschen älter schon, ja. Und Gesell war halt eher Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts. Und die Idee dabei ist zu sagen, okay, also da gibt es halt so Coupons, die man draufkleben muss, um das Geld weiter im Umlauf zu halten. Oder es gibt dann noch ein Abrisssystem, bei dem das Geld halt entwertet wird. Das heißt also, ja, noch zu 30 ist er gestorben. Und der Anreiz besteht eben darin, dass du weißt, am Ende des Monats wird dein Geld, keine Ahnung, 5 Prozent weniger wert. Oder am Ende des Jahres wird dein Geld 10 Prozent weniger wert. Und wenn du es verhindern möchtest, dann gibst es halt aus. Also investierst du es in irgendwas. Und diese Schongeldverfahren werden halt häufig in so kleinen Lokalwährungen, von denen es etliche gibt, verwendet. Muss man mal sagen, so viele Regionen versuchen durch so lokale Währungen, die dann, was ist das irgendwie, Grüntaler oder sowas heißen, wird halt versucht, die lokale Wirtschaft anzukurbeln. Also man sagt halt, okay, diese Währung gilt halt nur in dieser Region und kann nur bei regionalen Betrieben für Sachen ausgegeben werden, für irgendwie Obst oder Haare schneiden oder Kinder vorlesen oder was auch immer.
Ist das nicht eher ein Marketing-Gimick? Sowas wie, wenn du in Disneyland irgendwie spezielle Disney-Dollars kriegst und dann am Ende ist dir das zu blöde, die zurückzuwechseln?
Na die Idee dabei ist, ist ja eher, dass man sagt, es soll halt eine Währung sein, die nur in der Realwirtschaft passiert, also die halt kein Geld mehr zum Zockerkapitalismus hat. Das heißt, die kannst du nicht anlegen in irgendwelche Derivatscheiße, sondern die kannst du nur ausgeben für reale Sachen.
Wieso, das ist doch eine Frage, wenn sich ein Armlöchter findet und Derivate in der Währung anbietet. Was machst du denn dann? Verhaftet man da was?
Nee, aber das sorgt ja schon Geld dafür, dass es keinen Sinn macht, weil du das Geld ja nicht investieren kannst.
Na du kannst irgendwie über Umrechnungen...
Na es wird ja 10% weniger wert. Und bei diesen Mini-Währungen ist es in der Regel so, dass es halt eine offizielle Umtauschstelle gibt. Natürlich gibt es Schwarzumtausch, ganz klar. Passiert halt immer. Aber man versucht halt eben dadurch zu sagen, dass man den Geltungsraum möglichst begrenzt zu halten, die lokale Wirtschaft anzukuppeln. Funktioniert natürlich alles hinten und vorne nicht, weil es eben darauf beruht, dass die Leute gutwillig sind. Also wenn du halt irgendwie...
Bezügliche auch fast alle, bis auf diese Banker.
Genau. Also wenn wir einfach die Banker... Aber lassen wir das. Oma Erziehungslage gibt es ja nicht mehr. Und die Idee hinter diesen Schuldwährungen ist halt dafür zu sorgen, dass sie halt ausschließlich realwirtschaftsbezogen sind. Also keine Investitionen in Zocker-Derivate stattfinden. Und dass der Geldumlauf möglichst schnell gehalten wird. Das heißt also, dass das Geld nirgendwo festklemmt, nur weil irgendjemand gerade denkt, dass die Wirtschaft gerade mal runter ist. Und das nicht ausgeben will, sondern dass halt einfach dafür gesorgt wird, dass das Geld immer schnell ausgegeben wird. Und dadurch die Wirtschaft halt nie stockt, weil halt irgendjemand denkt irgendwie, jetzt könnte es gerade mal ein bisschen scheiße sein und man hebt das Geld lieber zusammen. Und so lokale Experimente damit sind halt verschiedenerfolgreicher, es gibt erfolgreichere, es gibt weniger erfolgreichere. Wie immer ist natürlich auch da, treten die beiden Phänomene auf, nämlich a, dass es halt geschlossene Theorien sind, die nicht faszifiziert werden können. Und b, dass sie halt mit irgendwie einem Bin-Jargon versehen werden, der dazu führt, dass es ein bisschen schwierig ist.
Das ist in der Wirtschaftstheorie echt das Problem, dass da jeder erstmal seine eigenen Wörter erfindet.
Wo man so ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten hat, dahinter zu gucken. Aber jedenfalls lohnt es, das mal zu lesen. Es ist nicht gänzlich abwegig. Wenn wir uns überlegen, wie Alternativen zum jetzigen Währungssystem nach dem Kollaps aussehen werden.
Das können erst mal.
Dann kann es halt durchaus sein, dass so eine Elemente aus dieser Schundgeldtheorie und dieser Freirirtschaft da durchaus reinfließen. Vielleicht sind es ja aus mehreren Bereichen Sachen zum einen elektronisches Geld mit bestimmten Eigenschaften, zum anderen möglicherweise Schundgeldverfahren. Da gibt es sicherlich eine Menge Elemente, die da zusammenkommen müssen, um halt irgendwie das Geld für nach dem Kollaps darzustellen.
Tja, wenn nächsten Monat der Kollaps eintritt, was kaufst du dann heute?
Werkzeuge, Saatgut.
Essen?
Essen, ja. So Sachen, mit denen man um die Bar was anfangen kann und Sachen, die meine persönlichen Fähigkeiten und Fertigkeiten unterstützen.
Bücher?
Bücher zum Beispiel, ja. Also es ist halt sicherlich eine interessante Frage, die man sich so stellen kann. Ich meine, der Kollaps wird nicht im nächsten Monat eintreten und nicht 100 Prozent sein. Aber es könnte halt schon sein, dass es mal etwas anders kommt, als wir uns das heute so vorstellen. Und darüber nachzudenken, welche Werte sind real und welche Werte sind nur irgendwelche komischen Derivate?
Und welche Werte sind nur Verhandlungssache?
Versprechungen und welche Werte beruhen nur darauf, dass man Vereinbarungen mit anderen Menschen hat, die sich dann plötzlich daran nicht mehr erinnern? Die zu stellen, ist auf jeden Fall sehr sinnvoll, wenn man irgendwie sich überlegen will, wo man sein Geld lässt, falls man auch welche hat.
Ja, das wär es möglich.
Damit sind wir dann mal wieder durch. Dieses Recording haben wir schon mal in unserem neuen Aufnahmestudio, was wir natürlich mit anderen Leuten teilen, in der neuen Raumfahrt-Agentur. Das ist ein Raumklanglabor. Hier haben wir so einen hübschen...
So ein toller Raum.
Halbwegs schallgedämmt.
Schallgedämmt, aber das Problem ist, wenn man die Schalldämmung perfekt macht, indem man die Tür schließt, dann wird es zufrahm.
Ja gut, da arbeiten wir noch dran, aber...
Gibt noch so Detailprobleme.
Gibt noch so Detailprobleme und wir haben, wie ihr gehört habt, jetzt auch ein neues Stuhl quietschen.
Wir haben ein neues Stuhl quietschen. Viel besser als das Alte, finde ich.
Da wäre wir eher melodischer irgendwie. Da werden wir noch dran arbeiten. Ja, ansonsten vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Wenn ihr uns noch mal ein bisschen Geld rüberrücken wollt.
Keine Bitcoins, bitte.
Ja, ich nehme in meinem Blog die Bitcoins des Experiments halber. Ansonsten greifen wir gerade auf das gute, altbewährte Flatte zurück. Ansonsten wollten wir noch was zu T-Shirts sagen?
Zu T-Shirts? Ja, ich glaube, das habe ich sogar verlinkt. Lass mich das kurz prüfen.
Also es gibt jetzt Alternativlos T-Shirts?
Ja, das Logo haben wir ja von unserem, ich will nicht sagen Fan, aber unser Freund, er hat geistig das Logo gemacht und hat es unter die Beerware-Lizenz gestellt. Das heißt, das kann man frei benutzen. Aber wenn man ihn trifft, dann soll man ihm ein Bier ausgeben.
Genau.
Und wir haben uns überlegt, naja, das ist ja eine schöne Lizenz. Eigentlich kann sich jeder seine eigenen T-Shirts machen, aber wie das so ist, die meisten sind faul. Und ein T-Shirt laden wir dann angefragt und dem haben wir dann halt gesagt, er kann das mal machen. Und das haben wir unten, ganz unten auf der Alternativlos Webseite verlinkt. Und da kann man dieses T-Shirt kaufen. Das kostet halt irgendwie normal viel Geld. Das ist jetzt nicht besonders teuer. Wir haben mit dem auch verhandelt, ob wir da Provision kriegen. Aber das gibt irgendwie steuerliche Nachteile. Deswegen machen wir das jetzt nicht.
Das heißt, wir haben da nicht viel von, aber auf jeden Fall wird Erdgeist sein Bier bekommen.
Es ist Kleidsagen und wir werden Erdgeist auch sein Bier kaufen.
Ja, und damit dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal.